the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
[Music]
[Music]
so
welcome everybody to beautiful bucharest
romania host of the superbad chess
classic the inaugural stop of the 2022
grand chess tour behind me is the
majestic romanian athenian one of the
most beautiful concert halls in europe
the players are ready to compete the
fans are ready to cheer for their
favorite superstars and we are ready to
call all the action let's go to the
studio and start today's round with
yasser peter and alejandra
welcome to the coverage of the 2022
grand chess tour as we look at these
beautiful shots of romania
here in the st louis studios
i am
eventually peter sliddler
you're good you did it good peter um no
no i didn't but yeah that's so that's
the kind of a hard of things to come i'm
peter svidler and with me is the one the
only uh yes sarah one i'm very happy to
be here and uh let's talk some chess
absolutely peter big big st louis
welcome to you great to have you back
and staying here hello everyone and
welcome to our live coverage of the 2022
grand chess store we are getting started
and what an incredible
roster of players we have for you
peter please do us the honors and tell
us
absolutely it is a very very strong
tournament as you will see on your
screen uh in a moment
we'll pass passover to alejandra in a
moment to give you a more detailed look
at some of the players but uh the three
i wanted to uh highlight are 5b up top
there 2793 uh rating and mvl
and live on iranian because uh i think
they are the the players who have played
in every single grand chess tour so far
and they continue being absolutely the
stalwarts and and and the the mainstays
of the tour and obviously legends uh
legends all of them and perhaps one more
mention has to go to uh richard rapport
who is
one of the hottest players
on the scene right now and uh qualified
for the candidates after having a
fantastic fantastic grand prix series
absolutely we can't let it go without
also mentioning alireza our youngest
participant and also the hottest
prospect in the markets uh tell us about
the format
yeah the format is uh it's a templar
round round robin
as as you have seen uh the time control
is uh what i would call the feeder time
control because it used to be uh
and still is the official time control
for
the events yeah
it's 90 minutes for the first 40 moves
and then 30 minutes for the rest of the
game with the increments starting to
move on a 30 second increment
there is also as you can see on your
screen a very firm no draw offers in in
the tour
there is no cutoff there is just a very
firm statement of node offers and the
usual uh scoring system of one point for
a win half a point for a draw and
obviously no points for a loss and yes
in place here absolutely and our
schedule
uh the schedule is quite simple and a
very logical one uh we get five rounds
and then the rest day and then four
rounds to uh to finish the tournament
with potential playoffs if players are
tied for uh for first so plenty of chess
action to come in the next 10 days
wonderful and alejandro as always a
great pleasure to see you my friend in
studio uh drill down on some of these
players first please it's a great
pleasure to be here back in the 2022
grand chess tour of course one of my
favorite events i've been casting this
for quite a while and it's always
brought the thrills and spills let's
take a look at some of the other players
that you guys didn't mention of course
we have one of the headliners wesley so
he is the current defending champion of
the grand chester he won it last year
and it was not a fluke he had already
wanted very cleanly in 2016. last year
he had a little bit more of a bumble but
his first place in paris really
catapulted him to the top top of the
standings in the same field cup he
really needed to cruise and he crews he
did third place was more than good
enough to take the grand chest through
last year another person that really was
a headliner of last year it was the
world championship contender yane
pognachi he came into the world
championship with tons of expectations
the entirety of his country backing him
but was really unable to deliver i'm
sure that it was a tough blow but he is
backing the candidates next month he's
going to warm up with the grand chester
right here and of course he has a lot of
strong players one of them is a bit of a
wild yard he is the wild card for our
event spoken on daniel dayak he did play
last year as well in this superb chess
classic in romania he started off quite
well fell apart in the last couple of
rounds and didn't finish as well as he
should have but he definitely showed
that he can hang with the best players
in this tournament excited to see what
this young player has learned in one
year of chess and if he can really
improve on him results from last year
but from bucharest we have two special
special people we have anastasia and
christian kirilla live from there
thank you alejandra and welcome
everybody to bucharest romania the city
is buzzing with excitement for the start
of the 2022 super bad chess classic
yesterday we had an amazing day at the
opening ceremony we will be calling all
the action here from location i am your
host grandmaster christian carrillo and
i'm joined by my brilliant co-host
women's grand master anastasia
anastasia tell us a bit about
yesterday's opening ceremony it was
really amazing opening ceremony which
took place in the parliament of romania
i mean something really important and we
had more than 600 guests during this
event and there was a drawing afloat so
there were many speeches of the
officials and of course gary kasparov
himself was presented and he answered
numerous questions from the media
and then
you know
some players dream come came true they
could play against 10 top grandmasters
including also gary kasparov and it was
a fantastic simultaneous exhibition i
mean we had really great day i have to
say the organizers put together an
impeccable show yesterday today as well
as we are getting ready for the players
to arrive and start competing against
each other we see the buzz around the
playing hall a lot of spectators we have
100 seats in uh the playing hall for the
spectators to get close to the players
and watch the show we will be calling
all the action and sending you guys
updates from location here in bucharest
romania for now back to you in st louis
thank you christian and thank you
anastasia it seems like a very nice
things that are going on but let's take
a look at the pairings peter do the
honors absolutely
here are the pairings for round one and
conveniently for you in the middle of
the screen is the game which i think we
will be concentrating on uh provided
uh nothing else explodes
on other boards but uh all five all five
games here are very very interesting uh
wesley plays of the white pieces against
chakrima mijarov
mvl is white against lanier dominguez
then the game i was talking about fabi
with the white pieces against uh
alireza faroja a fantastic game to watch
and also
and there uh uh
we're interrupting our broadcast to see
gary kasparov make the first move on
that very board
uh
i wonder if gary has done this before i
think he probably he probably said he he
sat in in fabia's chair on hundreds of
occasions right but whether he's
actually done this or from this side is
uh
unclear to me ah i i think he's been
around i think he's done it now the
question there was i think he was just
actually asking uh the first maybe yeah
like what what's your intention dude
yeah e4 d4 c4 and yeah gary is i think
his sort of respect and love for chess
won't permit him to just like go 1g4
here or something even though it would
from him
from him particularly it would have been
would have been a nice gag but i don't
think it happened it's happening
alejandro predictions for fabi's opening
move
you know this is a very important
tournament for some of these players
because it's the last classical match
they will have before the candidates
this is certainly something that fabi
wants to put his foot down he doesn't
want to show his prep but still wants to
beat alireza he had a lot of success in
the american cup with the english
so it wouldn't surprise me that he
starts to move c4
okay and as you were mentioning the uh
candidates coming up next month
this is a big match because i'm thinking
that these two guys
uh are kind of the favorites
is that definitely definitely two of the
favorites two of the favorites
absolutely oh
there it is there it is c4 that's
predicted alejandro alejandro that's why
he gets paid the big bucks around
absolutely wait we got babies
they're hearty handshakes uh gary looked
to be in fine uh kettle there is a big
big smiles
as uh
chester
is underway peter and uh we didn't get a
chance it is as we've established over
the last year his brainchild yes
yes and one of the things that's
happened i hope everybody is aware
that the grand chess tour for next year
the two top finishers will
be feed a candidate so uh the grand
chest store
um
is in the fide cycle peter it is it is a
very interesting development and
obviously uh
it's very good to see uh
granchester and fide uh you know
cooperating
cooperating cooperating properly after
all these years still you know i assume
between now and 2023 there will have to
be
uh some conversations about the format
and how all of these things work and
already there have been some some some
things said about the classical being
perhaps featured more prominently
yeah and the money keeps improving peter
yeah uh the price fund here is uh is
absolutely stellar as you can see on
your screen there's a there's a cool uh
hundred grand up top for the winner of
this event very nice
figure i would say yeah
very very nice uh very nice uh bundle of
uh bundle of cash up open uh
the other column the gcc points column
perhaps needs some clarification because
we see you see clear points for uh
everything apart from the uh the top
prize where it says 12
13. that depends on whether you win it
outright or whether you die for first
and then when the tie breaks so you are
incentivized to win this tournament in
without without resorting to die breaks
so exactly uh and there is a you know a
very nice 10.5 uh for showing up at the
bottom there so yeah plenty uh plenty of
money to be earned and the games are
starting and fabi does indeed start with
1c4 so there wasn't a kind of a double
bluff there from uh from gary not at all
english uh peter well not really the
english anymore because no because there
is a decline yeah but it's just that the
english move order and we've been seeing
a lot of the c4 knight f3 b3s
those well c4 knight of three g3s those
as well yeah there's there's plenty one
c4 doesn't really uh define the game
yeah it very much depends on uh on what
the the opponent decides to do
and uh already we're seeing uh an
interesting uh an interesting uh
approach from from marie reza because i
think
uh
he generally i i i wanted to go off on a
bit of a not a rant exactly but but a
bit of a tangent about him him being a
young exciting player who plays sort of
young exciting openings but then old man
and then i got interrupted by happenings
on the board and then my second train of
thought also got interrupted because he
took on d5 for the pawn and not the
knight exactly when i saw the move over
then we should probably start actually
uh showing what's happening because well
we have the traditional queens gambit
declined with knight
bishop g5 and you were just about to
mention
that
the the modern appearance the cemetery
the cemeteries is a very very topical
opening and people have been playing
quite a lot of it and as per usual
much uh much of the reason for the
popularity of this line can be traced
back to vladimir kramnik at some point
starting to play it yeah as with with
many other things right in modern chess
chess theory of the la i don't know last
15 years or so maybe maybe even more but
instead of playing the modern line with
knight takes d5 as you say vladimir
kramnik certainly trail blaze that line
the old traditional e6 takes d5 was ali
reza's choice bishop g5 and i assume c6
although uh yeah he went c6 e3 h6 e3
which already slightly surprises me and
i honestly i kind of want to pass the
baton to you here yes because i have a
feeling you have much much more
experience in the carlsbads of all kinds
than i do because i
generally don't play these structures
right with either color well for me i
especially like to include the move h7
h6 based on the variation
of bishop f5 which i've played
and then
this line that kind of tigran petrossian
blazed
we get into this ending that is was also
featured actually in the american
cup um uh sam savion versus wesley so
and one of the problems that black often
faces in this is this move h2h4
and the idea that is that at some point
black may play h6 or h5 in view of
somehow the bishop getting trapped so
getting in the move h7 h6 in my view is
a real plus
if your intention is to play this bishop
f5 which he hasn't which he has it
which is kind of strange because you are
too youssef to mention one name
uh
if you're not going to play bishop f5
you're going to play bishop e7 then in
archer's world you leave the pawn on
seven
rook lifts and the rest of it yeah you
you really aren't supposed to soften up
your your king-size structure like this
without a very specific reason and uh
yeah it's it's a little bit mystifying
to me exactly what already is aiming for
here uh i'm guessing you can still play
for you know the usual 94 uh
plans of trading of trading pieces this
way
but
yeah it's it's interesting even though i
think i've seen people do this more
often these days just uh
seemingly like optically to my eyes this
allows white everything everything white
could possibly have wanted like a three
bishop ii now is a is a very comfortable
way to uh solidify your situation in the
center and then try to push for
uh e3 for later which is uh the sort of
the most classical way of achieving an
advantage in the structures but uh
concretely i guess these days chess has
become much more
much more about concrete concrete
evaluations and concrete sequences
and i think less about long-term plans
i'm guessing
this holds i'm guessing people have come
to the conclusion that you can also do
this
and and not not suffer over much but
to my eyes i would be extremely happy
with white here i would think you know
i'm being given
a lot of freedom to do whatever it is
that i want to do very good and
alejandro what has caught your attention
in this opening round
well yasser there are some openings that
i prefer over others when i'm a chess
spectator or commentator one that i'm
not so fond of even though i spent
the better part of half a year analyzing
is the petrov defense and we actually
have two petrov's today two appearances
and they're going in completely
different directions the first one i'm
going to look at is mvl maxima sherlock
graph against linear dominance and
linear who's a traditional spanish
player as well as night or player has
added the petrov to his repertoire with
great success remember that he beat
lavonna ronyan in the american cup only
a couple of weeks ago and actually
almost beat him the second time they
played in a petrov in the rapid portion
of that tournament in the elimination
bracket and he's bringing the petrov yet
again here to bucharest very clearly
showing that he's added it fully to his
repertoire and we're gonna have a little
bit of a twist in this one after the
moves uh knight takes e5
i can get knight takes e5
d6 but the maximum one knight d3 the
move knight f3 is of course by far the
most common move but knight d3 has been
seen a couple of times five has faced
this with the black pieces pretty often
he faced it in the world championship
match against magnus carlsen in 2018 so
it's a well-known move knight takes
queen e2 queen e7 queen knight f4 is
supposed to be the idea knight d5 is
actually a deadly threat but there's a
couple of ways to deal with most people
go for knight c6 with the idea that on
knight d5 you have this resource knight
d4 and somehow this works out for black
just fine and instead of that most
people have figured out that uh this
game to some kind of draw chan games and
people stop playing the movie knight d3
altogether i don't know if there's any
new twists in the move knight c6 but
lanier wanted nothing to do with that
instead immediately retreated the knight
to f6 a little bit more passive just
saying go ahead and trade queens i'm not
really worried about any of the end
games even if white has theoretically a
slight plus because the knight on f4 is
better than on f6 not the most exciting
stuff in the other hand uh in the game
between
sorry that's another one i wanted to do
they go between the pontiac and bogdan
dayak bogdan has also uh tried to use
the petra but completely different
scenario nepo is actually using one of
his favorite lines knight takes c4 the
move d4 instead of knight takes e5 which
i think has recently gained a lot of
popularity saw it in the grand prix a
couple of times bishop d3 d5 knight
takes e59d7 and starting with the move
order of knight c3 we did see this in
the american cup as well in the women's
section so a couple of petrov
developments the patch of making clearly
a comeback in fashion not something i'm
thrilled about but you know chess is a
very concrete game and draw with black
is fine absolutely and it's nice to see
well
nice is it relative term but
the petrov
generally speaking opening theory very
much is uh subject to subject to fashion
i
things appear and disappear seemingly at
random
sometimes it just is very very
mystifying why people just stop stop
playing things which appear to be doing
quite well but yeah the petrol
definitely is
bouncing back i don't know if it ever
really went away but now people people
are playing more of it these days i
think it's
kind of surpassing the berlin again
uh in terms of like the the the the fail
safe the absolute rock solid choice uh
if you if you want to be safe with black
against one e4 yeah well that makes
sense right you don't have to study the
italians
people realize you can actually move the
bishop to c4 instead of b5 and then
people thought why play knight c6 just
play knight f6 less of an opening and it
seems to be the way that a lot of
players are switching around the
repertoire yeah that actually makes up
makes a lot of sense i think that you
may have solved that particular
crime there yeah i wanted to draw your
attention back uh peter to the game of
afabi and uh ali reza i think this is
going to be our marquee match-up for
much of round one and before the moves
knight beats
bd7 and a2 a4 got played
you were opinion
of the opinion that white has got a lot
in this queen's gambling decline uh
which is kind of confounding to me
to me if you put the knight on f3
everybody's seen this thousands of
times but uh from the world championship
matches between two k's and sparrow from
karpov we learned a lot that oftentimes
the knight on e2 is simply more flexible
as we're about to mention f2 f3 and
whatnot uh
expand on on your thought process in my
mind that that goes back maybe even to
like the the the era of between and uh
for some reason
all the positions in which white's
perhaps major plan involves playing of
three four and then goes to bad finish
you just immediately i immediately
attach the name between it to it and
stop thinking right
but the interesting development here and
we'll come back to f3e4 in a moment the
interesting development here is knight
bd7a4 right which is very complicated
as well which which sounds like a
complete non-sequitur and uh
that doesn't connect to anything and i
think once again this is guess work but
it's sort of
it it hints at it very very heavily
and this is something that people have
been doing more and more
despite and once again i want to say
this is a very modern development and i
guess you know if somebody tried doing
this against but vinik you know they
would get kicked out of the betweening
school
i think people actually play b5 yeah b7
b5 quite a lot in these structures for
example
f3 b5 i think actually is uh uh an
interesting maybe in the next video
remember that f3 f3 b5 was played
between magnus carlson with the white
pieces and then the rest of uruguay
himself in 2020 so alireza's not
unfamiliar with this territory it's
certainly you know botvinnik didn't have
uh stockfish
and it's all very fair yeah and the
computers do suggest a ford stopping
this b5 plan so that white can focus on
f3 bishop f2 and immediately ucla
wrestle reacting to this plan
and let's take a look at the lifetime
between these two players that
head-to-head not a lot of games between
them of course alireza is extremely
young and extremely talented but he has
not played as many top level tournaments
as fabi has two wins for the american i
believe one of them was out of vikanze
and i'm blanking on the other and three
draws
has never gotten the best of fabiano
caruana so far but of course there's
going to be a rivalry for the aegis very
young alares i will be playing at least
twice more against favi next month in
the candidates
very nice
and the move knight h5 is a move that is
very common
in these queen's gambit declines the
idea is to force the trade of this
bishop i mean the move a2 a4 to stop b7
b5 seems like quite the luxury to my
eyes as white really is about to play f2
f3 take command in the center and that's
why black played this
yeah knight h5 is a very logical
continuation i'm still somewhat curious
as to why knight h5 has been preferred
to let's say 94 but
both of them seem seem playable to me
and
i think
perhaps this is where my absolute lack
of understanding of the structures
shines through but
maybe the idea against 94 is to take on
e7 and then perhaps after queen takes e7
we can take on e4 with the bishop okay
and try playing g45 straight away this
could be one way to perhaps
uh you know use the fact that our knight
is on isu and not on f3 meaning that we
don't have to spend the tempo moving it
away from from f3 because it would have
been hanging on a three-in-right
i don't know if this works tactically
because we are providing black with a
very nice d3 square for the g7 knight
like knight c5 or maybe even knight e5
it's a it's a very concrete position it
might not work at all for y but if it
does it might give white uh some
advantage knight h5 is a more
is a more sort of conservative option
because it doesn't offer white
any ways of changing the structure just
yet
and it also i think very effectively at
least for the time being stops all the
dreams of f3 and d4 because after
bishop 727 which has already been played
that's what i wanted to say f2 f3 is
going to be very hard
i'm assuming we play a5 here yeah and
he's already played a5 yeah like
i didn't manage to do it before before
he actually did it on that screen but
but you were reaching for that i was
approaching because i mean the obvious
drawback of playing a2a4 in this
structure
uh and a5 we're being told is a novelty
so all of this
has actually been played up up to and
including bhp seven queen takes e7 uh
it's a very logical move here because
yeah as as as i was saying uh playing
a2a4 in the casbah structure
makes your potential minority attacks on
the queen side much less
promising exactly yeah because in
particular if black plays a7 a5 you you
will kind of struggle to play before
comfortably and by playing a5
uh you at least you know set up a
situation where if eventually you get to
play b2b4
uh the the c5 square which is the usual
target for one of white's knights is
going to be uh
available for us to perhaps sort of base
our play
around having said all that
uh
if black plays a7 a6 here which i don't
know if they should but it's obviously
an option and now let's just make some
random moves just to illustrate my point
let's say we go i don't know ruby one
doesn't matter okay
i go out on the knight age five of six
just to bring it back it has to go back
at some point before we go i don't know
night of eight right night a4 right and
in particular if i can manage i think 94
here is a big mistake actually because i
think black is very very happy given the
chance to trade the bishop on c8 for one
of the knights so we go bishop g4 here
gotcha and we trade him and we take only
two next next move f2 f3 would just
invite queen takes e3 so there's no
stopping yeah as you say a pre-move yeah
but my my sort of a larger point here is
that the knight on c5 is an absolutely
gorgeous piece yeah take a photo but but
how do you make any progress right
there's no break yeah black just goes
rook 88 96 and just chills right
because the one remaining pawn break you
have here is once again going back to f3
and d4 but it's going to be extremely
difficult to realize with all of the
black all of black's pieces in the
center and putting pressure against the
white center exactly
so
it's it's possible to even sort of allow
everything white ones here and still
have a position which is
going to be passive
but
extremely solid and it might actually
sort of uh
become even promising for black if white
over presses because i think without
sort of overpressing white really
doesn't have anything in this structure
so i'm very curious as to how this will
how this will progress let me turn it
over to alejandro as you've got a
traditional slav on your board aleandro
it started like a traditional slav
yasser as you can see on the board this
is the game between levon aronian and
richard rapport and richard always
brings something new to the table some
interesting little twist this is clearly
a normal slap the main lines are 95 and
e3 levon chooses 95 which is the most
common move knight bd7 has become the
main line in this position knight takes
c4 knight b6 this is all well known
knight e5 a5 is almost always automatic
f3 knight fd7
and the line goes knight takes d7 and
everybody here automatically recaptures
with the knight uh i think everybody has
done that e5 coming in very quickly this
is a line that morozevic used to play
pretty much all the time he uh was
really the man that brought it into the
forefront of theory but richard says why
take with the knight this bishop is
gonna get hit anyway why don't i just
take with the bishop and then bury it on
the next move with bishop take d7 e4 and
e6 this is not how i was told how to
play chess
but this bishop is buried this is a
strong pawn center for levon and even so
after the move bishop f4 which looks
like a very logical developing move to
me of course i think bishop e3 might be
a little bit more logical the computer
says zeros like black is completely fine
in this position and i just don't
understand why you have a little bit of
a space advantage the bishop on d7 to me
is just a bad piece the computer must be
eyeing the possibilities of a break with
c5 maybe even e5 at some day that will
liberate black's pieces successfully i
like white already in this position but
the computer just simply does not agree
with it's an interesting one confounding
yeah the the structure is very nice and
particularly you you keep on drawing
attention to the bishop on d7 which is
kind of bad but also the knight on b6 is
just such a nice experience
yeah i'm i'm curious as to why this
works because clearly he is not ad
leaving here clearly he is prepared yeah
he has figured out that this is a
playable way to to treat this position
but yeah it looks it looks kind of bad
it looks ugly
i mean no no no seriously if i if i
brought you peter and i said look here
in st louis we've got this really
promising talent he's 12 years old and
he's he
he's a genius and uh please and and he
he shows you he shows you his favorite
game and it starts out with this
position
and you look at me like
you're like what are you doing
who is this kid i mean it feels like
richard's breaking a lot of rules yeah
but these days these days you're more
and more allowed to break break rules in
the opening if you put enough work in
castle's castles yeah i'm guessing this
is sort of the uh the the major the
the major sticking point is that you you
can afford to
do things which you really are you know
according to you know classical
knowledge such as uh you you really
aren't supposed to be doing uh getting
away
as long as you've put in you've put in
the hours and you've
you've actually figured out how to
justify it and here if you if you look
at plans involving c65 and if white
doesn't have a if white doesn't have a
good reply to c65 you can see how the
black position is is sort of rapidly
improving uh
yeah put some pressure on the a4 pawns i
mean on g6 it might be dead on c6 it uh
you have to start looking at tactics
with bishop d6
but that is not a tactic right i do have
the counter tactic of bishop takes a4
yeah that's that's very clever i was
looking at exchange sacrifices me too
but the counter attack looks really
strong there alejandro honestly i think
i think she thinks d4 is completely also
fade queen f8 and i'm very oh chill
content yeah with black as well because
queen before bishop c5 loses the queen
exactly uh but yeah bishop takes a4 is
simpler as alejandro is pointing out
just right winning material on the spot
right
another critical i suspect question to
the evaluation of this position is
whether we can play g4 d5 right
trying to prevent white from achieving
all of those objectives but yeah there
is plenty of counterplay here queen f6
six as yesterday's pointing out is one
way to deal with this i'm curious about
even something very kind of a
caveman ish like take on c3 maybe even
first right then take on d5 and then
creating an idea of bishop takes a4
because we are threatening uh the bishop
on e2 in the end
and the bishop doesn't really have a
good square so you have to make a kind
of an awkward move here perhaps rook f2
perhaps rookie one and maybe even i can
uh although yeah having
looked at this a bit more i feel like
it's 5 a.m lack of coffee speaking
because morning saint louis this is rit
because i was actually suggesting taking
on a fight on d5 but i think
yeah the two bishops might be a little
too strong but just to show our audience
what peter is contemplating he's
sacrificing two pieces for two pawns and
a rook but the two pieces that are on
the board are two vicious and open
positions
this is one thing and the other thing is
my structure on the queen side is too
broken up because exactly this would
have been perhaps workable if the pawn
was on c6 yeah
and you can immediately play before
maybe life's uh working uh alejandro
weigh in on this uh richer rapport uh
approach to this age-old opening well
good morning st louis and luckily for me
i have an engine so i can't blunder as
much
after the move d5 which you guys were
suggesting yeah c5 of course is a very
logical break i like the move d5 but it
just doesn't work tactically after
bishop takes c3 pawn takes c3 pawn takes
d5 pawn takes d5 we got uh so far but
just play queen f6 oh yeah thanks just
gloves and things just collapse you
can't defend this pawn and this pawn and
this bishop and this pawn just too many
things hanging for the white side at the
best you have some compensation for
whatever pawn you decide to lose but
it's murky at best you're probably just
fighting for equality which really begs
the question what is levon planning
against the move c5 d5 doesn't seem to
work c takes d4 is coming on the board
the engine actually just says you have
to
say this didn't really work out the move
bishop f4 was not a good move according
to the engine you have to take check
king h1 and of course black is in no
real danger in this position the queen
comes to e7 the rooks come to the middle
of the board black's position more or
less place itself out i don't know if
bishop takes design was a bluff if it
was some sort of deep analysis but if
black plays c5 at least my engine is
saying he solved all of his opening
problems and perhaps even a little more
call me an optimist challenging your
engine at five in the morning
but the that variation where you had the
queen on f6 for a second only yeah it
goes d4d5 that's what there is yeah
there is the move bishop c7 just going
to let's that's very good bishop c7
unfortunately and then it goes for the
peace sacrifice it's not a sacrifice
yeah there's queen e7 at the end this is
a very nice little
put it on
on the board oh that's a pretty double
attack and this is a very nice it's a
very easy double attack to miss as well
right this backward moves hitting both
bishops but 27 is quite nice what's not
lost uh you are losing an exchange and a
pawn but somehow the pawn gives you
enough counter play where black not much
is
winning but it's of course not white's
intention yeah no no no no
okay very very nice and again uh
uh by the way there is a way for our
audience to participate in our
discussion absolutely yeah we we welcome
we welcome all all all
constructive criticism and answers no we
don't no we don't
and the way to do it is to to tweet at
us you can use the the hashtag
grandchild store or you could tag the ad
granchestore account and we will we will
be uh replying to
tweets on air
even when
we
intend to yes uh peter i i mean the
petrov defense has been for decades uh a
pain in the
butt
for uh one e4 players
has mvl gotten anything out of this
opening a little bit i guess right
i mean
i am
sort of a well well-known uh you know
bishop aficionado and it feels like
linear will have to play b6 right now
but i guess the structure is still fine
um i would be miffed at having to give
up the bishop player here but then again
the other bishop will come out to d6 and
e65
and e65 will happen reasonably quickly
and
uh yeah it's it's not that bad
i
i suspect there might be cleaner ways of
equalizing in this particular line but
it's still not very much
you know
nowadays computers are very greedy they
don't even want to give you bishop e60
really they just play they just play
knight e7 bishop d7 c6 ugly chess but
they're saying well the knight on f4 is
in the middle of your pieces it's in the
way of the bishop on c1 why do i want to
let you get rid of this just develop all
your pieces first it even goes h5 knight
f5 isn't no rush at all to castle oh my
goodness yeah it's and it thinks black's
just doing fine yeah 97 obviously i i
saw the move existed but i was kind of
really lucky yeah reluctant thing yeah i
think in that direction but
it's it's basically that that arrow that
uh yasser drew on 97 g6 that is
something that i was missing in this
picture c696 is just such an
uncomfortable way to continue here with
bishop coming out to d6 um yeah 97 is
perfectly playable yeah i guess i guess
there is nothing much wrong with it for
for me i was really kind of skeptical of
white's advantage at all 97 c6 uh was
not on my agenda either i didn't mind
giving up the bishop i mean i i have
played some
really well and truly lousy french
defenses in my life
i mean like really
really bad and i want to point out that
if we actually isn't the worst first
defense i've ever played against i want
to make a make a point here that the
bishop one of three uh you know it
provoked bishop b6 but after we trade on
e6 it's actually kind of misplaced
because you would perhaps like to play
f2f4 here right to stop the break uh
with the 65 but you have to spend so
much time on it that you probably just
never never actually have the time to
stop the 65 and once black played the 65
in these structures
they're normally just completely fine
yeah and alejandro jumping back to you
you've got a completely different game
of wesley so we have to take a look at
everybody of course wesley saw is
playing in shakira media if it's a quiet
affair in the opening so it hasn't
really come out with the fireworks that
we perhaps expected we had a very normal
nimzo indian with a normal twist
nowadays this move bishop d3 d5 and
instead of playing the move knight f3
immediately people seem to be taking on
d5 pretty commonly nowadays which is why
some black players have decided instead
of losing the move order of d5 has
started using the move order of c5
funnily enough they now lead to
different positions because after pawn
takes pawn takes the move seemed very
common here are queen c292 and the move
a3 all of which lead to slightly
different positions here bishop take c3
is certainly an alternative but very
common is to just retreat the bishop to
d6 queen c2 a6 and we'll get to the
position that we currently have on the
board after the move knight f4
it seems like an old style way of chess
the bishop coming to d6 with these
couple of pawns of course there will be
pressure almost eternally down the c
file but how do you get through this
bishop on d6 is a monster and of course
you can't really reach this bishop very
easily to the point where white is
basically sacrificing their structure
saying please take my knight with your
bishop i don't think black is ever going
to do that but uh perhaps a little bit
of pressure for the white side i don't
really know the computer says zero zero
i always felt that it's easier to play
these positions with white at least you
had a clear intention and you had a
little bit more space but it's not the
most ambitious approach that white can
uh essay against the nimble indian i
expect this to go through quiet affairs
for quite a few more moves but the same
i can say for most of the games today i
i wanted to point out something about
this position though that um it's only
quiet if you manage not to allow c7 c5 i
think
in this particular structure uh in in
the current position in particular with
the knight
going to f4 and
sort of not exerting any control over
the d4 square anymore if you play bishop
b7 i'm expecting wesley to just turbo
rook b1 here
because i think allowing c5 here just
dissolves absolutely everything and
playing rugby one and trying to at least
make c5 uncomfortable i mean it's
currently unplayable completely but
right if you have to play something like
rook b8 or queen c8 to sort of
reestablish the threat of c7 c5 white
clearly has gained something uh yeah
bishop 5 here is very annoying and ruby
8 in general is just not a move you are
extremely happy to make in these types
of structures right but on the other
hand if uh
if c5 is allowed if let's say after
bishop b7 we make some kind of a
blase move i don't know what like bishop
b2 or what have you
uh
and blake just goes c5 here i'm pretty
sure
i'm a massive liquidation i'm probably
picking black maybe wow ever so slightly
alejandro i i
i have this
memory
i remember being absolutely absolutely
stunned by it
it was a match between gary kasparov and
deep junior
so there we are calling all the action
everything's going very nice you know
gary has some position exactly like this
and instead of the move b7 b6 or any
other kind of move the computer goes
bishop takes h2 check
fall out of our seats and gary
looked like he saw a ghost
when the computer plays king
bishop takes h2 check against you
and let's just say you know yeah when it
works it works
that was god that was out of the draw
right yes
things got very fun very and it was a
wicked
wicked draw
was i mean it's ridiculous was bishop
takes h2 check
i don't think it was the game yeah i
don't think no that was the semislav
game i remember that game right
but it was shocking yeah
castle
uh bishop takes h2 here yeah let's just
throw it down plus four let's see king
takes we go on a little bit of a walk
yeah we can't go back let me just show
this to the audience you can't go back
as queen h4 finishes the game no good
way to defend against queen h2 checkmate
rook summer queen takes f2 is winning uh
so you have to actually go king marching
forward but that's pretty much the end
of the attack unfortunately for black
they lack some of the important squares
to go back to for example the move queen
g5 threatening some kind of discovery
f4 is important it hits the queen shoots
it away where this queen is defended uh
so the queen has to go to the h file
okay and then you don't have to do i
guess yeah sorry and then just bishop d2
i guess
queen h6 looks good yeah bishop d2
queen h2 is a very nice check but it's
just a check and after king f3 since
your queen is now getting trapped with
the move rook h1 you have to go queen h4
threatening knight h2 is not a bad
threat unfortunately for black after g3
this square becomes available for the
king the king does a little bit of a run
around but it's perfectly safe and white
ends up a ton of material ahead it just
does not work tactically um at all
pretty much so bishop takes h2 is a nice
idea but it does not work in this
position and wesley's certainly not
going to be defeated by a greek gift a
greek yeah uh could you go back to queen
h6 for just a second because it was just
like one of those moments oh yeah maybe
we played bishop d2 and life's good go
ahead bishop d2
knight e3 is ridiculous because you can
go king of two simply i think just take
it king f2 the kingdom of two is very
safe yeah we just don't have enough
attackers here right well white house
white has a great amount of attackers
what do you mean
yeah yeah yeah yeah the the pieces on
the queen side are sleeping very much
depending on the definition of we
talk about white we have places right
but it okay so b7 b6 and
by the way i just wanted to ask
the uh are we following current dictates
of theory anything new uh not much that
i can see uh there's a couple of games
already here and he takes d5 uh a3 is
already kind of rare 92 is such a major
line of the nimzo indian a3 is not seen
very much there's so many grand master
games but nothing too major and already
here after the move bishop d6 we only
have uh like 10 games in the database
that are that are relevant so
not much to speak about when it comes to
opening theory black's supposed to be
okay in these variations as opposed to
being okay for a very long time it's
just a practical approach to the game
more than some kind of theoretical uh
theory some theoretical approach by
wesley in this game
and how do they match up
well the lifetime between these two one
win three losses so actually they are
getting a little bit of the better here
again so
and not shockingly 12 draws between
these players
so they know each other well but that's
a
i mean when you think of wesley so as
the returning grand chess tour champion
you don't expect him to have a negative
score of three losses and one win
turning our attention back to our
marquee matchup absolutely we didn't see
too much when we left it you would peter
you'd said well i can understand a5 and
you know if you can get in that whole b4
complex landon knight on c5
yes yes yes after some thought
alireza actually did play 786 so
freezing the queen side pretty much in
place and
just preventing
the kind of move a6 which might
cause issues with the backward pawn on
the c file okay a7 a6 and then
fabi's in a pause yeah he's thinking and
and perhaps this is a good time for us
to uh to actually
talk about those you know long
long-winded plans that i was so yes
please i was so disparaging about
earlier jump right in yeah and
i've already mentioned i think one very
crucial concept when we talk about this
position in these structures in general
and that
white re apart from the obvious idea of
landing one knight on c5 you can do it
with this knight you can also in some
positions i guess go knight knight e2 c1
b3 c5 i don't know which one you prefer
i think it depends on the circumstances
both of them will look quite nice and
quite nice on on the c5 square
but the big uh the big
talking point here uh i think is that
bishop on c8
okay and uh
white needs to uh i think expend a lot
of effort here to make sure it doesn't
get traded for
anything it needs to stay on the board
for white to have any chance of an
advantage which is exactly why and this
is why we were talking about this
at the start you you'd mentioned it's
very important not
for white to allow bishop e2 which can't
be met by f3 since queen takes
absolutely
i think it's probably the central
uh the central kind of a story line for
the next uh for the next few moves
because
uh you you you really hate the idea of
spending a tempo on something like h3
which is why
i guess one way to avoid it would be to
sort of unpin the knight on e2 by
playing i don't know queen d to queen c2
somewhere to at least be able to if
black actually ventures uh ventures
fourth with now the bishop g4 you can go
knight g3 or knight c1
uh just not let the bishop take
some take on it again if i can from the
audience perspective just pick your
brain and say if black were allowed to
take his bishop on c8 off the board and
any one of your knights any one of the
ladies and you're just saying oh he's
just solved so much of his problems i
think he's immediately completely fine
as far as like that would be my
assessment that yeah if if the bishop
once again gets traded for any any of
the
uh corresponding light pieces on the
white side
black just puts one knight on f6 the
other knight on e6 because rook 88 and
says yes i don't have any active plans
but the moment you start doing something
all of those pieces will make a lot of
sense so it sounds to me more and more
like if we go down this primrose path
where we just put some moves on the
board
and uh you put your bishop on
and in such a case now
we're cooking with gas
and i actually prefer an ic one to knife
g3 because in general i feel like
keeping pieces on the board here might
be in white's favor so i don't
particularly like offering a trade on g3
either
so if the central break is going to be
e3 e4 and white's going to get need to
play f2 f3 at some point this knight on
e2 has got to move so you can defend the
pawn on e3
a little bit awkward alejandro for white
to get anything
what do the engines say computers are
computers and they find inhuman ways of
rerouting the pieces i think the first
move that the engine likes is quite
natural i like the move knight c1 for
all of the reasons that you guys
explained also the knight b3 idea with
c5 coming that's very natural to me
what's not natural is how the engine
follows it up after the move knight f6
the engine also thinks the move queen g5
by the way might be an idea just to keep
the pieces on the king's head and put
some pressure like that but let's take a
look at these kind of positions because
knight f6 seemed to be like a very
natural move to me in this position the
computer immediately wants to go rookie
one but it was also suggesting moves
like queen f3 with the idea of putting
the queen on g3 and controlling some of
the dark squares which i've never seen
in a carlsbad but once you put the queen
on g3 it makes some sense right the
queen does exert some pressure of in
some of the dark squares but the engine
is saying go knight c1 knight hf6 you
can start with the move rookie one and
if they go something like knight f8 then
f3 and not e4 immediately put pawn on f3
the knight on b3 and hint that you're
gonna play the move e4 doesn't actually
play it it just hints that you want to
play e4 at some point and maneuver
slowly the bishop actually at some point
retreats to f1 the knight makes a
pretense that it jumps to c5 but it
doesn't fully again because there's
going to be a knight on b3 and not on a4
this knight is obviously going to jump
to e6 and then it seems like the pieces
just freeze and white starts maneuvering
slowly preparing e4 eventually but not
immediately and this is a game that is
going to be a lot about long maneuvers
if white wants to get anything if black
the computer really does not like
playing like this for black it actually
thinks that after knight c1 this move
queen g5 keeping pieces on this side of
the board might be the better way to
play it it does seem a little loose in
my opinion and of course the attacks on
the king side might just not pan out but
i like starting with the move knight c1
because it solves so many of the issues
that peter was talking about and it hits
a knight you never know when they're not
going to move it
and well you mentioned sorry to
introduce you peter you mentioned that
ali reza has actually played this
position before sort of yes and uh just
cite those uh games and his approach if
you will well uh let me go back to the
novelty of a4 here knight bd7 and i'll
just jump to this game between alireza
with uh the black pieces i believe
against carlson yeah uh f3
yes he was black and this game went f3
bishop f2 as peter suggested immediately
but you can see that alioreza expanded
with the move b5 and it's a completely
different beast even though we have a
very similar structure the fact that b5
was allowed is both good and bad for
black it leaves a weakness on c6 you
leave some things that white can work
with but on the other hand black does
get a lot of space it does have the
ability to kick out this knight from c3
so the center is certainly much
more unstable and the game was uh it was
fun but
eventually i don't really know which one
of the manual requests that carlson is
having in this database is but
eventually got to such a position where
you can claim that white still has a
little something something because of
the pawn on d5 but it's clear the black
has pretty active pieces as well there's
some targets on e3 the knight on five is
nice but it could get kicked out someday
by bishop f8 and g6 the game ended up in
a fighting draw but i don't think that
alireza minded too much the position
that he got in this game
and uh well when you play this against
magnus carlsen it shows that uh
ali reza was absolutely prepared for
this and it couldn't have been too much
of a surprise for
the one thing i was i was going to
mention which we haven't actually
touched very much on uh is uh the clock
situation in this game because uh
alireza is still pretty much uh
as you can see on your screens he
started with uh
90 minutes and he's down to 87 34. so
he clearly isn't very surprised by any
of these developments and
a4 being the novelty
these days if it's something you are
seriously preparing i'm guessing a4 is
not going to be a novelty for you
because you've looked at you know both
of these guys have looked at the same
sort of a readout on their screen
exactly if the engine suggests a4 it's
unsurprising that terereza is aware of
the existence of this idea
what is a bit surprising is that
uh as we have just heard alejandro
describe
engines are not entirely in love with
this for black and it doesn't seem to be
you know quote unquote mathematically
equal
but i i guess he just feels comfortable
in this structure and feels it's okay
and doesn't really mind
perhaps being a bit worse out of the
opening here but yeah he he clearly
despite despite fabie being the first
one to deviate he clearly is still very
much uh very much in his comfort zone in
terms of opening prep well uh
you you
i mean for me this move queen g5 is
actually a
rather attractive looking move that you
don't automatically step back and
passively wait for white to slowly build
up the f3 e4 break that we all know
is coming sooner or later but the move
queen g5 is kind of just
throws down a little bit of a gauntlet
right a kind of a challenge this knight
is potentially routing and bishop h3
would suddenly
uh be a smack
absolutely
you know
i think the major point here is not that
you you have you know realistic hopes of
launching an attack on the king side
it's just that if you don't do this
white pretty much has an absolutely free
hand to do whatever uh whatever they
please and uh
it's not a particularly good situation
for black to be in considering you know
their lack of potential pawn breaks so
you do have to give white
at least something to think about right
and this is what this set up with queen
g5 and knight f6 does and also i want to
point out that apart from the bishop h3
you keep on pointing out bishop f5 is
perfectly one yeah is coming back to the
idea of needing to trade away the bishop
on c8 exactly there's another thing here
that is very attractive for black yeah
the as you say just get rid of this
bishop on c8 put your work on e7 with
your central control white's f3 e4 is
not frightening anybody okay well we'll
definitely keep an eye on bobby after
some thought here played a move which we
didn't look at didn't look at and
wouldn't have been i'm yeah i think you
could anybody's agenda give me quite a
high number of guesses here before i
came to rook a3 i think uh i would be
close to 12 myself
queen c2 queen d2
there's plenty that comes before okay
three it's interesting yeah i'm not
entirely sure i have a feeling it's
it's more to do perhaps with
uh
i don't know what it does on b3
well it defends e3 yeah i think it yeah
exactly yeah i think it actually defends
e3 eventually right not right now but
maybe he wants to play something like
bishop b1 and then
uh
or something and eventually having the
option of playing f2f3 with the rook on
a3 supporting the pawn on e3 is is going
to be useful and also he is sort of
postponing knight c1 so that like if you
play queen g5 anyway here
perhaps having knight only 2 is
something that white
will feel uh will feel quite quite good
about alejandro looks artificial
to my eyes
what says the engine let's say you the
engine says that the top 12 moves were
about 0.3 anyways for white so it didn't
really matter which one you chose knight
c1 was it stop move but it says rook a3
is just about as a good move as any of
the others where it does change the next
few moves in uh what white wants to
achieve this knight will probably not be
seeing itself on c1 the engine wants to
play g6 i don't think g6 will appear on
the board it's a little bit too deep for
me but let's play a normal move i like
the move knight f8 i think that's where
the knight should go at some point uh
the engine thinks that this is go the
way that white wants to play knight a4 i
put in the move knight e6 because i
think this is a normal move
it already hates what i did by the way
um and it does say that the rook will
come to b3 and the the thing i found
potentially a tactical justification for
what we're doing is instead of knight e6
here you go bishop g4 which is a move
that we always wanted but maybe you can
play f3 here f3 is playable because yeah
and rook f2 queen takes e3 check rook f2
threatens both bishop h7 with a
discovery on the queen and of course the
bishop on g4 and you have no good way of
avoiding both threats white actually
wins in this position so it does have a
tactical justification in that sense um
that bishop g4 is not allowed in this
position
wow uh rook a3 uh yeah a bizarre move to
my eyes but uh somehow it works by the
way the reason why uh g7 g6 i actually
know this from my own practice
it's a very common for black to seek to
play a series of moves that goes knight
f6 knight g7 and bishop and then
so that you know you get this very
desirable trade absolutely yes uh one
thing i would point out that i do like
about rook a3 and what am i saying let
me slap myself uh
queen g5 just doesn't feel
right i feel that in the lighting
yeah with the knight still on e2 i could
easily trip up and maybe the rook slides
across the board definitely something to
keep an eye on what's happening
alejandro
not in the richard rapport game i was i
was curious if richard got in the move
f3 or not but at c5 or not sorry go
ahead actually richard thought for not
so long play the move rook cn instead of
c5 i'm not entirely sure what scared him
out of the move c5 or if in fact he just
thought that movie rook c8 was more
precise
levon has gone into a deep think after
this move certainly not a huge time
difference it is still classical chess
but i don't really know which way he
wants to play for an advantage here it
has to do something with the fact that
the moment you play c5 i'm going to have
access to knight b5 knight d6 perhaps
try to get the pair of bishops somehow
but it's not going to be a very easy
thing to do levon has been thinking for
22 minutes the engine wants to play the
prophylactic move king h1 so that on c5
if i ever have to take on c5 it's not a
check or if you take on d4 you won't be
pinning my eventual queen the lance on
this diagonal so with king h1 makes a
lot of sense still a 22 minute thing
here for uh levon neronian i don't think
he got as much he's actually wait what
somebody told me to play rook f2 that's
why you think for 20 minutes five
minutes you play king h1 22 minutes you
play rookie i think i think the point
here is that he badly wants to be able
to meet c5 with d5 exactly and he is
sort of
uh in some way feels that this prepares
it better even though i still don't
understand why let's say the exact same
thing we were doing in the previous
position doesn't work like we take on c3
which is
yeah exactly it works better right it
looks stronger it looks it is stronger
bishop takes pawn takes pawn takes pawn
takes queen f6 and in many variations
where i was giving up the c3 pawn this
rook wasn't hanging the queen could do
something active but here when i hang
this pawn this this rook now the queen
is tethered to this one the rook and f2
is not actually very naturally placed
the engines think this is actually
almost uh decisive advantage for the
black side wow so rook f2 so what's the
replied to c5 then machine p3 or
something the engine wants to play
knight a2 things that are not going to
happen for for a lot of money but knight
a2 runs into knight takes a4 this seems
to actually work for black let me see
how this works
knight takes it actually takes with the
c pawn yay and then queen takes d4 in
there yeah i can i can definitely
imagine this working oh this actually
totally works yes i can see that now the
rook on f2 is
awkward
it's a terrible rook and yeah rook c2 is
coming as a major threat queen takes b2
also a major threat yes you have a pair
of bishops and they're not the most
useful bishops right now and the engine
loving black in this position thinking
this is not actually playable uh so i'm
at a loss at the moment on what he wants
to play against the move c5 i also don't
see a not a lot of other moves for black
you don't have a move that is as useful
as whites right he can play with rook c1
he can play a lot of useful moves but
black is running out of useful moves
rookie 8 queen e7 are the last couple
and i would argue that the queen on the
8 in many variations like the one that
we just saw is useful it's useful on the
a not on e7 yeah so it seems like the
time to strike maybe he wants to play
like night knight b5 that's the thing
that's because we lose material yeah we
just
take on d4 yeah this doesn't work at all
no no i i'm not entirely sure what he
wants to do against c5 c5 looks like a
very good break to me
absolutely and we we will show you some
some news from on-site and some
developments in the in the new promising
day out game take over christian
thank you guys uh yes indeed i was uh
strolling uh to the playing hall i was
trying to understand the feeling uh of
the players as well as their spirit and
i have to say one alireza ferrugia is a
definitely very confident i've been uh
seeing him strolling around his board
watching fabiano up closely he's
definitely a matured player we know he
took a five months break after that
explosion from 2780 to around 20 28.03
plus and right now he's getting ready
for the candidates so he's a dilemma for
us we don't know exactly what is he
going to bring to the table is he are
going to use the preparation that surely
he has been uh trying to gather for the
past five months in this tournament or
is he going try to shield away and uh
and uh wait for that to show it during
the candidates he's definitely a player
that we are all having our eyes on but
another player that that we're
definitely having our eyes on and one
that performed admirably last year is
bogdan dayak the youngster from romania
he's been taking a bit of a break as
well at the beginning of the year he did
not play in the romanian championship so
right now he's coming back with a lot of
new fresh ideas also it seems like he's
playing some sort of a new opening for
him i remember him as a rudy lopez type
of player for black but it seems like
nowadays everybody is uh taking over and
starting to play the petra the russian
defense and of course we know that nepo
surely must be ready for the petrov is
one of the openings that he definitely
had some preparation going into the
world championship match of course we
know when during a match uh with the
black pieces you're trying to equalize
so definitely he has some residual
understanding and preparation from his
match against magnus carlsen so let's
see where that took us this clash of
ideas a new player playing the petrov as
well as a very experienced nipple with
the white pieces with a lot of
preparation behind him he started off
with e4 e5 knight to f3 knight to f6 we
also saw dominguez pick up the petrov as
well recently and d4
not the move knight takes e5
which we know is the main line d4 knight
takes e4 of course one of the other
options is to take on d4 and that leads
to some crazy complications it's a line
as well after e5 but knight takes c4 is
the main line bishop to d3 d5 and
generally now we see uh e d takes e5 but
as well as knight takes e5 which uh
recently has become sort of a main line
keeping the structure as it is compact
and uh right now with the inclusion of
these knights on e4 and e5 well white is
going to try to target potentially that
knight on e4 and let's see uh what uh
happened what transpired in the game
right to d7 knight to c3 b take c3
knight takes e5 d takes e5 bishop to c5
and right now queen to h5 and it does
seem like this was the first uh thing
for uh daniel bogdan the act because
after queen to h5 you can go h6 you can
also go queen to e7 bishop to e6 but he
chose this interesting move opening up
the dark squares for a white species
this move g6 which i understand but he
did spend a lot of time and i don't know
how aware of uh of the complications
arising after this and we see queen to
h6 bishop to f8 of course you have to
kick away that queen from the f8 h6
diagonal otherwise you won't be able to
castle queen to e3
and now we have queen to e7 and a4
i do like white's position quite a lot i
was looking through some lines what if
he doesn't go queen to e7 what if he
continues with a move a bishop to e7 and
try to short castle well the problem is
right now as white i have a lot of
useful moves that i can play i can play
the move a4 as we've seen in the game i
can go rook to b1 as we've seen uh as
well and i know jan was definitely
prepared for this route to b1 the
problem is i'm waiting for you to go
castle and as soon as you go castle i'm
going to come at you with the move h4
it's a very very dangerous position for
black you cannot take that pawn on h4
because you're just simply going to
resign in one move so what dak is trying
right now queen to e7 and after a4 that
was actually uh thinking for the past 28
minutes that's a huge thing now
obviously he's hinting that he's looking
for a different plan he does not want
castle on the king's side he could
potentially castle on the king's side
with bishop to g7 but once again he's
going to be subject to a vicious attack
after h4 so perhaps right now what that
is looking to do is to go bishop to d7
or bishop to e6 and castle on the other
side a very interesting uh moment right
now but i have a feeling that jan really
knows uh what to expect from this
position as well as what to look for in
this position and i'm not 100 sure uh
bogdan deck is very much aware of where
to place his pieces this is going to be
a very difficult defense for the young
romanian guys back to you thank you
christian and i can't wait but to ask
you your opinion of this current
position peter yeah i like this for
white and i think what what christian
said there is is very much on point uh
that shouldn't really be a criticism if
if bogdan wanted to play the petrov in
this tournament he should be playing the
petrov but
having to play a somewhat new opening
for him in the first round again
somebody who prepared that opening
albeit with the different like jan was
playing it with black in the world
championship much but world championship
prep
is so extensive that you are almost
guaranteed to run into something which
has been
sort of bothering young himself
on the black side of it and
these days
the assumption always is that you know
this doesn't refute the opening probably
with an up with enough prep you can find
a way to
uh to solve the problems black black
black is facing but doing it over the
board versus somebody who has a very
very clear idea of what's going on it's
not going to be much
uh much fun for the young romanian and
he ended up playing the move queen e6
which looks very awkward but that's
actually my move there's still as we can
see
uh bogdan is still
burning the clock but i i see this move
bishop a3
i really don't want to play c yeah don't
want to play anymore
yeah
the move the move i was kind of looking
at was i was even uglier the even uglier
than big queen e6 yeah i was about to
suggest bishop f5 which is something
they do in these types of positions
sometimes because
the fact that you actually trade some
pieces off perhaps outweighs the
unspeakable things you're doing to your
structure by by playing bishop five here
but i am not obviously not in love with
this suggestion either like
i mean after this suggestion we're
definitely going to take a break but
before we go on break
uh we've got something from hugh
boutique yeah
we will have we'll have daily promotions
of of things you can find and this is
this is something that you can find at
cubaticstl.com
this is a lightweight cotton zip-up gray
jacket with pockets and you can never
have enough pockets so that's that's
very good features the gct logo on
on the top on the front left and yeah
the
cubitique stl.com is a sort of a
one-stop shop for many many chess
related and great gct related things and
uh this is the the item we're promoting
today absolutely and as we go on break
we're going to brace out to you some of
the opening ceremony that took place
earlier yesterday let's take a look
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the
bucharest granchester stage here we are
in the building of the romanian
parliament we are very excited to see
the opening ceremony and the drawing of
lots to learn who will be playing in the
first round let's go for it
[Music]
it's a great ceremony it's it's really a
beautiful place and it's quite rare that
you're you know in a parliament for for
an opening ceremony wow that was my
experience i mean beautiful environment
especially for chess i've never
i i don't recall being into the
parliament of my own country actually so
you know being uh being here is really
spectacular
i'm very pleased to be here in in in
bucharest so where it's you know it's
the
chess
modern adventure of the game of just
eastern europe has started
[Music]
yeah really looking forward to to the
tournament once you get the parents you
know
your opponent for the first round
immediately you start thinking what
you're going to play but yeah it was
really great the opening ceremony
[Music]
it's been an amazing opening ceremony we
saw the drawing of lots we saw the
simultaneous exhibition and now let's
come back to the exciting games
[Music]
can you hear it
it's the sound of hope
[Music]
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
[Music]
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
it's the sound of personalized
healthcare
and active communities
it sounds like life
and it's what you hear
when you really listen
listening to you caring for you we are
ascension
founded in 1839 the university of
missouri is steeped in tradition the
recently founded mizzou chess program is
a partnership between the university of
missouri and the st louis chess club
collegiate jess has been experiencing a
meteoric rise at the national level
through its tradition of excellence
mizzou has always strived for the best
mizzou chess is working towards raising
the bar by bringing our institutions
ethos of respect responsibility
discovery and excellence to the
chessboard
by now you guys probably know there's a
lot to see and do in st louis but when
it comes to the art scene
there's more here than meets the eye
from lao meyer sculpture park and the
city garden to the stunning cathedral
basilica one of the largest mosaic
collections in the entire world
so if art is your thing
st louis is on display all year long
now that's an exhibit
st lou is always exploring
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello welcome back to our coverage of
the first event of the grand chester
2022 and here is a view of the playing
hall uh
spectators watching watching our
templars play
lots of very interesting games in
progress and yeah as you can see
the sheraton booker's hotel
looks like a very very nice venue to me
absolutely really great staging i always
love that beater that when the
organizers go out of the way to make a
very beautiful playing hall i just feel
like yeah that's why i'm playing chess
it's a nice video it's really really
really nice
and i remember uh
these uh tournaments most especially in
yugoslavia it was like the audience was
very knowledgeable
about chess too and i get the feeling
that the that uh in bucharest we're
going to have our audience very
knowledgeable let's just jump
immediately
into
this game that's our marquee matchup
game between fabi
and ali rija uh what has taken place
since we left peter uh yeah rook a3 was
the move that we were talking about 14
which
confused it it initially confused us
quite a bit and then i think we actually
landed on exactly what fabian meant
because i think fabi expected knight f8
to happen and knight a4 is the reply
here as we mentioned before going on a
break the big tactical point here and it
actually is a very big tactical point
because you really want to prevent this
bishop from being traded very desirable
bishop g4 yeah it can be met by f3 and
actually very importantly rook f2
specifically not king h1 because if you
play king h1 here that allows bishop f5
and bishop h7 check has been stopped
our big idea there was to play space
seven check and then win the queen on e3
how does it continue bishop five bishop
e4 does it not work how about gringey
queen g5 yeah it continues but it's a
mess but rook f2 on the other hand
protecting the knight on the only two
stars bishop f5 stops bishop another
bishop is hanging and also bishop h7
check is a major major threat and so
we're ending up being material ahead and
even worse at the end of the whole day
uh white still has
a near-death grip absolutely
material balance here is not not even
that horrible for black but black
probably will lose because of just how
how bad the structure on the clean side
is so now we see the hidden point of the
move rook a3 absolutely it denies bishop
g4 and then came rook b8 queen d2
and very quickly queen g5 yeah g5 is the
move that we were mentioning in a
slightly different setting perhaps with
queen g5 earlier with the idea of
putting the uh g7 knight on f6 would
have been slightly more active but even
here queen g5 makes a ton of sense
because you as yasser is absolutely
correctly pointing out the idea of
bishop five here is uh extremely
extremely important
for black's well-being if if white just
blithely goes something like knight c5
here let's do it and we go bishop five i
think
many of our problems immediately
disappear here
but now now can we see a point that
maybe
fabi had uh seen from afar
which is actually yeah it's it's
actually annoying yeah because i thought
i could play rookie seven and then i
realized that blunder is a pawn exactly
good morning uh st louis as we would say
at these moments so there is some
uh needling
going on here and alejandro in that game
between lavon and
richard what do you have for us
creativity this is the way that many
players describe richard report anish
giri was one of them he did a reddit ama
today and he was asked how to describe
some of the top players in the world
with one word and he chose creativity
for richard and we can see exactly why
we see in this position that richard
prepares to move rook c8 with with the
idea of c5 and the normal grandmaster c5
is the next move levant played rook f2
we didn't really know how this move
dealt with the move c5 but richard
didn't ask he just played the move
bishop e8 and said i'm going to improve
my bishop it's still not very clear
where i'm going and after the move
bishop f1 which seems normal that opens
up the rook on the second rank to even
prepare some of rook t2 to hold on to
the pawn on d4 in some variations
richard said
c5 none of c5 who cares about that f5 on
the board the other break in the
position this bishop's going to g6 pawn
takes e4 doesn't seem like a tactical
threat immediately because remember the
bishop on air f4 would be defended after
e4 as well but it seems to be difficult
for white to hold on to the center what
surprises me the most the engines
already think black is better in this
position which after the moves bishop d7
e8 and then f5 it looks weird to me but
they're just thinking look the pawn on
d4 is a little bit loose you can't play
rook d2 because of this problem with the
bishop on f4 losing a tempo is not so
easy to do you would like to just
retreat your bishop to g3 get it out of
the way but you can't do that because
after f4 the bishop is magically trapped
and
it's not actually trivial to deal with
the pressure that's going on in the
position you give black one free move
it's pretty obvious the bishop is going
to go to g6 keep pressuring on the e4
pawn and it doesn't become so easy to
actually move all of white's pieces from
the current positions that they have
perhaps levon got a little bit too
creative for himself with the moves rook
f2 and bishop f1 and richard is taking
full advantage of it i love the move f5
it's not exactly a traditional slav
break but it seems to work in this
position and levon may be in a little
bit of trouble nothing here so far but
it seems that black is taking over
wow remarkable and their lifetime scorer
yeah it's uh not
it's funny to think that uh that they've
only played this many games right
yeah yeah when you think about levonow
candidate players only playing seven
games against one another right actually
levon didn't qualify this year this time
this time but of course he's been in the
candidates many times right and it's a
startling picture of him though
[Laughter]
startling good good good good eye
and
for our viewers who may be uh joining us
just a little late peter tell them our
pairings yeah this is the the round
we're watching and we welcome we welcome
our new viewers uh we have five games
today uh the one that we will be
concentrating on the most i think is the
game between fabian and ereza they're in
the middle of your screen but there is
also wesley playing white against
jacqueline jaroff mvl dominguez is a
reasonably quiet petrov
there is this very sharp petrol picked
between yandeep nish and bogdan dayak
and
as
there's also that game that alejandro
just described the game between livon
iranian and uh richard rapport yeah and
for me i find myself
remarkably drawn to the game between uh
ian and
bogdan yeah bog down um
break it down first peter uh it's just
not functional work yeah yeah exactly
when we left it not fun at all yeah we
left it in a position where
g7 g6 these moves as described by
christian were all being played
and then this move a2 a4 just seemed to
freeze
young romania yeah queen e7 i think he
was still playing quite quickly up to e7
included and then a4
put him put him into uh
a tank yeah he he he thought for a long
long time here and went with queen c5
queen a5 you don't play queen c5 uh
because you know queen g2 is going to
happen white obviously is not going to
allow the trade of queens and queen
takes e3 check is also not going to be
allowed so you have to you have to have
a reply to queen g2 and the reply was
queen a5 and now i very much like the
move room v1 which came very very
quickly that this is uh jan i i think in
his element he loves these kind of
chaotic positions and this move rook b1
is an instant form it kind of freezes
uh any
ideas that black might have
before before the break yeah christian
uh christian was suggesting that perhaps
black is kind of doing poorly enough to
start thinking about castling queenside
rupee one rugby one makes it very very
difficult to even attempt
any of that because yeah b7 pawn will be
hanging if the bishop goes anywhere and
b6 bishop b5 check kind of loses on the
spot so
you you can't do that either right uh so
he
like you you
need to try to make bishop g7 work is my
feeling i think anything else is just
going to be too slow but the issue with
bishop g7 is
uh
i'm
i suspect you might just be lost after
bishop p3 or i mean lost maybe is strong
but like your bishop a3 is a very strong
move here but black has a surprising
retort here after the move bishop a3 see
if you guys can find it that actually
gives black equality it's not more than
that but it does equalize the position
d4 is not it the bishop on g7 actually
is in a bad spot and you really really
want to castle you really want to trade
that bishop on a3 the move bishop f8
doesn't quite do the trick because after
bishop takes fade you're still in a kind
of awkward tangle it's the move bishop
h6 a very easy move
to miss
yeah that's uh i missed i missed that
entirely yeah that's a very clever idea
yeah yeah yeah yeah
takes you three and then queen takes a
three and uh yeah it's eight o'clock in
the morning here in st louis don't don't
that's right the engine does not care
what time it is
don't try that bishop h6 stuff on us
i mean
we'll come over here
but it seems necessary because as you
guys are mentioning beautiful move you
guys were mentioning how difficult that
black's position becomes after most
things right you can't really develop
this bishop too easily if you move it to
something like e7 even this structures
are not easy but nepal might just say
why not h4 exactly and just go kill the
guy h4 you can't castle cause h5 you
don't want to play h5 yourself because
after castles if you castle you'll die
to something queen h6 at some point will
destroy you this queen on a5 is very
severely misplaced so it does come down
to the fact that black needs to find a
couple of tactics to finish his
development otherwise he's going to be
in a world of hurt so a big time
difference already between jan and
daniel
to be expected as jan is such a fast
player i remember
precisely with this type of structure he
beat yu yang yi in the 2019 world team
championship
where he actually spent i think about 10
minutes of time thinking but the
increment was so great that he ended up
with more time on his clock than
what he started with and one easily
young
young
is very very lethal in these types of
positions he is he is very uh very good
at exploiting these edges and uh yeah
clearly as you can see on your screen
right now yeah bogdan is suffering
bogdan is in uh in in trouble here the
position might not be uh
beyond repair yet but
yes it has this feeling yeah yeah but
the combination of you know now being
quite severely behind on time even
though i do mention that like one of the
things i definitely know about about
bogdan is that he is very much
a time travel merchant so he will be you
know he probably will be in severe time
travel in this game but it will not be
the first time and he will be
sort of reasonably comfortable in that
situation because he's been there before
you know in as much as people can be
comfortable in severe time travel
against right he will be uh he will be
sort of okay with it
but but yeah the combination of the the
position probably not being very good uh
playing against somebody who is
confident clearly knows what they're
doing and
uh well
not a good trend and the pressure on the
clock all of that is not yeah it's not
boding well let's take a quick look at
the mvl versus linear game again that
was the another pet drop
very quick hopefully very quick uh
bishop f3 just checking in knight e7 was
the move uh that we had talked about
that the computer actually liked i
thought okay bishop e6 but 97 and look
at this it all goes very swimmingly for
black as it strikes me it's got no
nothing
to complain about whatsoever
this this might be an important decision
right right about now because uh
knight g3
is a bit of an annoying threat to the
bishop on f5 because we don't have that
many great squares so i would like to
find a comfortable way here to trade
some pieces which doesn't include me
taking on f4 because i don't want to
develop the bishop on c1 4 white and
having said all these things is bishop
g4 a good move
yeah i was about to say bishop e4 and or
bishop g5 i think bishop has a tactical
problem because i think i take you don't
want to be taking g-takes before that
creates a weakness no i didn't yeah and
if you think with the knight i have
knight takes g5 right
and this might not work out all that
great for black as far as i can tell i
think you just kind of lose material and
i'd have two i can continue with this
with the stupidity of knight take c7 and
you know does it still it's
but because of the point of knight d5 is
what attracted your eye to this to
well if i can't go bishop
i think if black has a comfortable way
here of trading specifically the
light-squared bishops
the structure is
so symmetrical and so solid that there
shouldn't really be very much to indeed
to press for white okay
uh going uh over to our game uh this was
wesley so's game as shaq
uh
when we left it you had mentioned that
the one thing that black really wants to
achieve is c7 c5 if you played the
desirable bishop b7
yeah
yeah rook f1
rook b1 i beg your pardon bishop b7 rook
b1 is what you specifically mentioned
peter as a way of really slowing down
this move c5 uh shaq said you know what
i'm going to do it the hard way
interestingly we kind of mentioned that
bishop takes a 4 exists but will never
ever be played
ever never ever commentator's curse
absolutely and uh
actually took i think quite a bit of
time on that decision and then just went
with bishop takes f4 specifically
followed by c5 without the follow up
with c7 c5 i'm pretty sure bishop takes
a 4 does indeed never get played exactly
but because it's because it can be
followed up by immediately putting some
pressure on the white center this is
what shakhir ended up with
and the current position i very much
as a spectator here sort of i very much
like the move c5 c4 because i think
shakira is about to sacrifice some
material because uh after bishop
one i think bishop one is
a kind of a wiser move than bishop five
because i think you do want to have some
control over the back rank here
yeah because i think d5 d4 is very much
on the mind here for black i don't know
how this works i think in this position
it might not work with the bishop f1
specifically because i can just take on
d4 not even
and not have to worry about rookie one
mate uh but
sort of a larger point here is that to
make the point that if i if i play
bishop f5 d4 is a possibility i think i
think yeah something like this must be
uh shakira's intention because if you
let's say you play bishop five and you
make a waiting move of some sort i don't
know some some kind of a stupid move
like h7h6 just to make a give white a
tempo and i play bishop b2 here well i
love white this looks horrible the
bishop gets to defense this is fantastic
the bishop gets to d4 the knight returns
to c3 and black is just like
strategically busted exactly it's very
very bad for black
so the move c5 c4 in particular played
after a long thing here does
indicate very very heavily to me that
shakhriar is intending to take this from
you know we were expecting a kind of a
slow
positional
shuffle yes for quite some time in this
game instead i have a feeling we're
going to have a brawl
okay well that's that which is good as
well
absolutely i mean it's still uh a
question to me you know like i'm i'm the
pawn grubber yeah
you know you still gotta justify the
whole pawn sacrifice i have no idea how
but maybe bishop d5 bishop b3 here
is one stable
i mean i mean queen d3 is possible none
of this seems forced none of this seems
obvious but exactly but on the other
hand when you just as you're saying like
this is a very
consequent decision when you play this
move and you see that this bishop is
about to land on d4 strategically you
better have a good solution and your
suspicion is that that good solution is
based on d5 d4
and
by the way we have a very experienced
group of roster players as many have
played in all the gct tours i i i i
alluded to it earlier yeah there we have
three players here who played on every
single tour that's fabi uh mbl and levon
we have wesley
played in six and was the a wild card in
the one that he missed i see and pretty
much everybody uh you know dip their
toes into
into the gct circuit
the numbers you see are full tours it's
not tournaments it's full tours and for
me the one that's kind of funny is
lanier dominguez he's played once
as a full tour participants but he's
been four times
a wild card candidate so he's certainly
familiar but uh a very very deserving
tour player and
absolutely for ali riza it's nice to see
this young man 18 years young
uh alejandro that's to talk about that
for just a second 18 years young and
he's in the world's top 10 and
everybody's pretty top ten he's he's a
top three right now three he used to be
top two until dingler and won a couple
of rating points good point everybody's
watching him the only reason that people
haven't been talking about him in the
last couple of months because he hasn't
played this is his first appearance in
chess in quite a while i think it's
since vikanze and everybody's trying to
see
yeah january yeah in january
everybody's trying to see what he's
going to bring to the candidates he's
the hot new thing to talk about he's the
new 2800 everybody's expecting him to
become the new magnus carlsen and of
course there's all these expectations
that build up on the teenager who's
shown he's a superstar the only question
remaining is can he actually make it to
the very top of chess which will include
that match against magnus the candidate
is his first huge appearance in in such
a tournament first opportunity he
qualified there handily he won the first
qualification uh
tournament that he could play sorry the
second after the world cup right and he
did so handedly he had a little bit of
trouble actually against my student
dario schwiertz in that one in a totally
lost position but outside of that game
he pretty much cruised through the
tournament he just played amazing chess
and everybody's talking about
this youngster now let me bring you back
to this game because i had the
understanding that you guys had of this
position that black is busted
strategically right and i hated the way
shaq has played it the computers say
we're all idiots uh this is obviously
0.00 black is completely fine in this
position what are you even talking about
after the movement by five which looks
very com very normal to me the engines
simply say look this bishop wants to go
to b2 right and this is an amazing
diagonal don't let it just don't let it
do that go queen c7 the bishop can't go
to b2 because you hang this pawn and
surprisingly it asks a very stupid but
difficult to answer question how do you
defend this pawn because you want to put
this bishop here and you never want to
go g3 because now d4 simply wins queen
c6 you're going to get mated on this
diagonal that's the end of the game
clear so queen c7 poses a a dilemma
that's not as easy as you would think
how do you get this bishop on this
diagonal you could start with a move
like bishop e3 or something like that
but as long as the bishop is not
bothering me uh specifically on the
knight on f6 i can move this guy around
i can go knight f896 or knight f8 knight
g6 pressure this pawn yet again the
knight doesn't have like a great retreat
it can't even go to c5 and the engines
don't care it starts trading off the
pieces bishop c8 gets rid of the pair of
bishops and he starts thinking that
black could have chances of taking over
the initiative so my understanding of
church just went poof out the window i
don't know why it likes black so much i
hate this hanging pawns that are blocked
but the engines think the black's doing
great
i'm with you on that one i just threw my
playbook in the rubbish bin because i
mean i like that position for white i'm
thinking the bishop on e3 is good i'm
thinking the knight on c5 is terrific
yeah that final position i can sort of
see how how black will be
doing better than we originally thought
because the bishop on b7 which is you
know the the two ways of reviving
reviving the black position would be one
to find the way to play g5 d4 or second
one
which is what we saw uh alejandro do
there on the screen traded for the
bishop on f5 uh getting rid of uh
arguably the
the one piece that black needs to trade
away it is just such a remarkable
conception that in this position after
the knight goes back
that you just go bishop c8 and zeros
yeah this is a very very non-obvious and
i i i wonder if that is actually what
what chocolatier is intending because
uh it's possible that he's correctly
assessed something like this or it's
possible that he found some somewhat
speculative pawn sacrifice somewhere
after bishop five and his
is you know intended going in that
direction intending to be much more much
more adventurous we'll we will see but
yeah it's a it's a very interesting
position to discuss and as alejandro was
mentioning creativity of richard reports
just got me
flummoxed i want to say this whole uh
concept after rook f2 i mean i think c6
c5 my hand
could not physically stop me it would be
difficult to restrain myself exactly but
he did he did restrain himself with his
exceptional move of bishop e8 i just
bishop f1 seems like a
reasonable move and then comes f7 f5
alejandro starts mentioning there are
issues suddenly facing white not exactly
the move you wanted to play g2 g3 bishop
g6 h4 and honestly i want to say that
with g3 and h4 i wonder whose creativity
here we need to be praising because this
is also a very very
you know non-obvious reply to black
researching exerting a lot of pressure
against your center
wow
and uh now is apparently the time for my
favoritest thing in the entire whole
whole world and that is predicting how
things will
uh come out are we talking today or the
whole tournament yeah the whole whole
tournament the whole tournament so who's
going to the maurice well yeah well
exactly well peter the problem is is i
haven't had much competition
uh around here in a long long long time
so that's why you in particular are so
very welcome and you being a guest
uh get the first
uh
are we only doing first place are we
doing the first place that's first first
yeah first place first
and magnus isn't yeah i'm aware yeah
i'll go with uh
alireza
nice
alejandra
yes sir yes sir
i'll let you get second pick i'll let
you get second pick you know
uh
he got off to a bad start at the
american cup he really did he didn't
impress anybody but fabi
when he got into his cruise mode he was
unstoppable
i'm predicting fabiano
i just want to spice up the candidates
if one player from this four is going to
win the tournament and say i am a
serious contender in madrid it's going
to be richer rapport so i'm going to go
with richard winning this one and
spicing up madrid
wow i like it 3 3 3.
and how about romania jump in christian
anastasia and var for that matter you
gotta get everybody in christian
well
well guys uh they say uh great minds uh
think alike uh and i know peter went
with ali reza i'm gonna have to join
peter on this one and i'm going to
choose ali reza i think for the past
five months he locked himself in his
chest bunker in france or perhaps he
went on a nice sunny vacation chess
vacation in spain who knows what he's
been doing he uh he's not online he's
not on instagram he doesn't spend a lot
of time on social media he's focused the
guy is focused the guy is ready to
perform and he's doing amazing as we are
getting closer to the candidates this is
what i'm expecting from him to do in
this event so i'm going to have to go
with ali reza also i really like his
position today so that's that
anastasia how about you i think if
shakira has made it once last year he
won the tournament probably he can
repeat his success again so i will bet
for shakuriya this time also i heard
that levon has some ambitions in this
tournament he said that last time he
came third but he is hoping to improve
his result so i think he can also try to
do something interesting here but
normally whatever i say doesn't work so
don't take it seriously
well we have a pretty varied set of
picks i have to say guys and varusian
verusian is choosing lavon so we have a
clash of titans between you
alejandro and var
as you have picked richard
and uh
var is going with lavon so this the
outcome of this game it's shame on us by
the way that none of us has picked the
grand chess tour champion winner wesley
soh
at all i mean wow it goes to show what
kind of field we've got here i think
that comes back to tradition right how
does wesley win the grand chess tours
and it's not usually in the classical
portions it's usually he gets most of
his points from the rapid and blitzes so
that's where he really excels he does
well in the classicals
he did win the sinkfield cup once when
he wanted in 2016 but
it's not usually his forte so when it
comes to the rapid and blitz i think i
will see a lot more people predicting
wesley to take it all
gotcha um talk about this clash of uh
titans here between levon and richard
this move h2h4 is not intuitively
obvious to me and i'm sure i think
i think the point of h4 is basically
levon is struggling to find a way a
comfortable way to protect his center
here and he's just saying my position
will actually improve if you win this
pawn on e4 like i will be upon down but
my position will start making a lot more
sense
so he basically chose a move which sort
of improves his position
for the eventuality of this happening i
think he probably plays c3 c4 here just
to take away the g5 square from the
knight on b6 there are other moves
available as well but i very much like
the idea of stopping knight very
consequent uh and then i mean white
definitely does have a decent
compensation for the pawn here i think
with being quite strong and the
inclusion of h2h4
gives you gives you some some additional
squares for the king perhaps in some
weird situations it might actually be
useful not to have to think about g7 g5
okay but mainly it's just a weighty move
and if you look back at the position of
move 17 up to g3 bishop g6 if we go all
the way back there just
yeah it's
until black actually resolves something
in the center you don't have very many
useful waiting moves i think it was just
basically just sort of the most the most
useful of the non-moves you can make
because
rook c1 yes looks fine but you know a4
might actually hang in some lines how
effective is this
bishop g2 bishop g2 doesn't look right
because
it just gives a gives up additional
squares like knight c4 might might
become interesting c65 might become
interesting and so on so i think h4
is
less of a proactive move and more just a
move which says uh you know please tell
me what we're playing here please tell
me if i'm upon down with bishops for
bishop and knight please tell me once
and and reheart actually says nope and
goes king h8
i'm not going to resolve the tension
either the center i'm not going to
up the ante with a move like c6 c5 which
again i mean i'm i'm you know the hand
i'm desperate to play the move c6 c5
you're reaching to do it but right not
not richie richie says no your position
is still awkward i can still refuse to
cash in i can still make some
improvements to to my situation before i
choose to do something in the center
please make more moves sir for me uh
peter and i don't know how your approach
but i absolutely love this type of
game uh where it's the battle of ideas
and it's not intuitively obvious for
either side and it always struck strikes
me that somehow
you know like the best players develop
plans that are really hidden in such
positions yeah it's it's a very
interesting interplay because it seems
like
something important is about to happen
in the center and the last the last two
moves we've seen on the board are
basically players saying on the flank
ps4
mainly just saying that you know there's
a lot of tension and i will wait for you
to resolve it i am not going to commit
to anything i feel like
uh
it's it's in your the ball is in your
court and richard just saying no i don't
agree i think uh i think i still have
useful moves to make
and i'm i'm not at all obliged to uh to
do anything it's a
sometimes these things are you know they
uh they fall under
if you if you look at it
sort of in the cold light of the the the
engine
some of this might be you know what i
what i like to call fps you know fancy
play syndrome this this might be play
synthetic this might be a bit fbsc here
but fancy but uh
on the other hand it might be it might
be extremely strong and uh
richard on good form is extremely
extremely good at these things he he
knows exactly how to you know balance
uh you know being creative and
unexpected and uh
difficult difficult to guess with just
playing good moves yeah he always
strikes me as a player that is willing
to up the ante to play risky positions
and to take a different approach for me
the move what i
despise is a strong word what i dislike
about the move
h2h4 is if i'm black in this position
i'm instantly drawn to the move rook
takes f4 like of course i understand
it's illegal it can't play it and she
takes f4 queen takes f4 but just as an
example of how uh the potential of king
h8 might work is something of this uh
i'm not losing e6 with check i can start
to think about what he takes
h4 and these types of exchange
sacrifices is what would pull me away
from the move h2h4 do you see any
drawbacks yourself to the move h or you
like
i mean i i kind of agree with you but i
think uh levon at no point is intending
to allow such an exchange change change
the structure in a way that would allow
rook takes a for like i think in in
lavon's mind the f file gets opened by
fe4 fe4 and then he always has the
recapture with the rook on f2 exactly uh
so that at least alleviates uh that
problem to a degree and once again you
never play knight you pretty much never
played knight takes e4
not only because of knight d5 but also
what takes f4 and fe fe as you said
always allows us so
what i want to say about h4 is
it's not that i like it necessarily and
also i also don't think levon is in love
with it
i think he is experiencing sort of a
scarcity of useful moves to make and he
is just doing something waiting as i
mentioned
for the tension in the center to get
resolved in some way and uh
yeah he's sort of back in back in the
exactly the same spot after king h8
again because you still need to make a
move i still don't like bishop g2 i
still don't like any of the queen moves
like you can play queen t3 but it feels
like it only invites trouble here like
windy 3 i can think about let's say fe4
or v4 95 for instance which didn't exist
a moment ago thank you because we're
eating the queen yeah because we've just
self-pinned ourselves yeah
95 now is at least something to consider
exactly i don't know if it's good but it
definitely is something to consider uh
so also i just want to point out that a
move like king h2 could have a real
drawback 65
the very logical the the rook hanging um
well as we ponder this one or rather as
lavon ponders this one let's turn it
back over to alejandro as our marquee
matchup is it heating up alejandro not
really heating up over the board we do
have some of the moves that we expected
but it seems like alaresa is curing all
of the problems of his position but more
importantly gaining a huge time
advantage on his opponent we see over
there the clock actually reads 28
minutes for fabi and an hour and eight
minutes for ali reza that is a very
significant time advantage considering
that we're barely out of the opening but
it does seem that favi does is not
comfortable with the position that he
got obviously he's not worse but where
is his advantage going to come through
he just played the move knight f4 and
guys you were talking over and over
again about how trading off this bishop
on c8 for any one of white's minor
pieces would alleviate the problems and
the question simply is after the move
knight g7 knight f4 what is the problem
with the move bishop f5 you're
threatening to i think i'm going to
speed soon yeah you might want to play
bishop a2 yes but is this really good
to play for an advantage you have three
pieces on the a file you're never really
getting e4 in knight e6 is a possibility
the engine wants to play h5h4 just to
grab space on the king side which is
also a logical plan now
alireza's position very solid one
weakness on b7 but that's not going to
be the end of the world you can't really
attack it too many times putting the
rook in front of the bishop is going to
be absolutely horrendous so i start to
wonder what are you playing for as wide
in this position e4 is unachievable you
could get a knight to c5 but then what
that's about you're only good piece and
you have to watch out for all the pieces
getting traded off with knight f8 to e6
or knight g7 to e6 and i just don't see
where white is heading towards in with
this position to gain any sort of
advantage i feel these knights on f4 and
a4 they're a little disconnected with
each other the only thing that they
could both do is target c5
and then all of them get traded and then
on a good day they all all get traded by
on a bad day there's problems with uh
some pins on on the d4 square because e3
uh is defending d4 but the queen on d2
is not defended so there will be some
tactical details that favi needs to
watch out for in the upcoming future the
engine already thinks that black is a
little bit better i think that's too
optimistic
but i think that he solved all of his
problems at the very least yeah no
bishop f5 certainly looks like the go-to
move and he has played it by this point
yeah i mean seriously uh
did
dioc solve his problems peter well we
were talking about bishop e7 as sort of
the safer option compared to bishop g7
just to remind everybody we left it
after the move rook b1
b7 yeah safer maybe not the right way to
describe it but sort of the
uh the the less adventurous because
bishop g7 would have been connected with
some very specific tactical
justifications or it might just lose the
bishop a3 as we were pointing out you
have to see bishop h6 uh in order to
play it at all i think that the problem
we had with bishop e7 was we were really
worried or at least alejandro pointed
out that h4 h5 is so compelling and if
you ever play h5 as black then castles
you're not castling and you're certainly
not grabbing this pawn on h4 as well
jan didn't do that
yeah he castled and played queen of four
and it doesn't look that horrible
anymore for black at first glance but i
think the sort of the large problem here
that uh
bogdan is perhaps facing is that queen
on a5 which isn't really
uh doing very much you can you can
grab the pawn on c3 but the the
suspicion is it might actually get you
mated because
immediately some ideas of bishop b2
followed by e6 queen h6 or e6 queen e5
might
get into play i'm a pawn
grabber one is certainly audio yeah yeah
that that feels radioactive i'm not sure
i want to really dabble there yeah
so the question is can i play something
like c7 c6 here to try to return the
queen to
normal-ish squares ysc-78
route jump on in uh alejandro how good
how bad is it let me start by telling
our viewers that when you look at a
position with an engine it's sometimes
difficult to parse exactly what it's
telling us there are many positions
where the engine says the evaluation is
0.00 and everything's equal but some
0.00 are different than others in this
kind of scenarios it thinks that bogdan
daniel dag has a very clear and very
precise
almost like a fine line that he has to
thread to be able to get to equality uh
because the move c6 already says black's
bust at h4 and and there's just no more
defense wow it says plus two and it
keeps growing it just thinks black's
gonna get mated on the king side
eventually and despite the fact that i
agree with all of you uh queen takes c3
would be
like the last move i really wanted to
play the i just think it's forced if you
don't take on c3 your position is just
falling apart after the move h4 you
might as well suffer for a pawn and
after taking h4 playing absolutely
bizarre moves he wants to put the queen
on c6 to return it this way but these
are very hard moves to find it just kind
of chills after h5 plays the move b6
only move by the way to keep equality
and you start seeing that 0.00 i don't
think so i don't think this is 0.00 i
think this is almost impossible to
navigate as black in order for full
equality and the thing is the thing i
don't like about black's positions
specifically
white's moves just find themselves h4 h5
if i'm down a part i'm a double pawn who
cares i'll probably mate the guy if i
don't make the guy i'm not worse
and you just go you go without any any
worry and black has to find
tactics not to get mated he has to find
some weird queen maneuvers to find
equality this looks like a very
difficult task i understand that the
petrov is in vogue but man if there is a
guy that's tried to beat the petrov
that's nepo he's tried these structures
a lot of the times very familiar with
them and he's just
once again saying i'm an expert
if you don't mind uh me n i'm not
playing to play the devil's advocate but
i just want to see how i get mated yes
let's say after the move queen f4 i'll
play a stupid move c5
you'll play h4
if you don't mind and i'll play queen c7
and just
why is this why does the computer just
go
gushing that this is so wonderful for
white right there's a couple of details
here uh yasser first of all
c5 is a decent move and this one has the
possibility of going c4 like in a french
defense scaring the bishop away from the
diagonal and gaining some important
space for your pieces and specifically
c5 to go back out to the for the queen
the problem with this move is to move c4
and strategically you don't have a good
way of answering with this i don't care
that i'm going to drop my pawn on a4
eventually this one is dead right i
really don't care about it if i force
you to play d4 which is pretty ugly then
i i do start with the move h4 i would
start with h4 the computer wants to go
queen g3 and bishop h6 first perhaps
with the idea of f4 f5 instead so
another avenue of attack here the move
queen g3 and going this way it just says
again plus three blacks busted you can
try to defend if you want it but no this
mission we don't want it anymore
[Laughter]
peter's throwing in the towel before
before
which is a good thing thanks for the
self-protection i i got your back too
one of these uh moments but that is
really uh
that being said um queen takes e3 is on
the board
wow so he has taken the bull by the
horse he said i don't want to suffer for
free i'm going to suffer for a pawn
right so quintex c3 has been played
i would expect the move h4 to come
rather quickly unless he thinks that
rook b3
really gains
much
which it might right it's a pretty
tempting move too yeah but the problem
is h3 is covered you know you're gonna
do a rook up and over but i love the
h4h5 just softening up the king side
even if you end up playing you know
queen g3 and bishop h6 but h4 h5
is a very topical thing here but one
thing i i wanted to just sort of please
not expand necessarily but
uh highlight something that alejandro
was saying there and it's it's a concept
which i think people
it sounds so simplistic that
i think people kind of underestimate how
important it is uh the concept of having
something to suffer for in these types
of positions okay because it looks like
if you're getting made it doesn't really
matter that you're a pawn up while while
you're getting mated because you know
you're
made trumps your material advantage but
uh the idea of having
something in the bank to at least let's
say be able to return it while defending
have have additional options of
you know sort of
trading some pieces while allowing the
restoration of material balance it's
about hope
uh
for a good ending exactly and knowing
that endings now are suddenly quite good
for you which allows you more leeway in
in defense this is a very very important
uh important defensive concept and as we
were saying nepo i mean queen of four
clearly signaled that he wants h4h5 so
he played h4 pretty much
uh
pretty much instantaneously here and by
the way um
for nepo uh
he first of all he's really ahead on the
clock one of the things that i see
constantly we've actually referred to
this is that when he's ahead on the
clock he is sometimes just a beast he
doesn't know you know you you just had a
20 minute thing you you make your move
you get up you're about to
luxuriate in the fact that you finally
reached the decision and he's answered
yeah by the time he's just stood up he's
extremely extremely dangerous in these
types of situations right and h4 comes
a la tempo very very quickly and you can
see the clock times is really screaming
uh the difference as uh dayaka is really
i think suffering uh we have h5
alejandro uh a move the engine's light
uh some developments in other games
bishop a2 was peter's idea this is ugly
but it's holding and the idea of h5 was
with the engine wanted to play the move
h4 grabbing space coming up soon e4 is
tough to play but playable this knight
will probably jump to e6 uh sometime
soon the question is how do you prepare
things for white in this case i think
the move knight c5 is something that
almost yells to be played
because this knight on a4 is not so
great the problem is that yeah you can
start playing knight fv6 if you're um an
engine you play knight d7 apparently
it's more accurate but i think humans
would play knight fv6 and just trade
everybody on e6 and why would black ever
really be worse in this position perhaps
even you can think of an advantage in
certain scenarios this bishop on a2 is
not so great so the question becomes how
do you make progress here with uh with
favi's position it's not so easy to just
shuffle randomly either because black
will play the move h4 he will play the
move 96 at some point his moves are also
coming together quite nicely rookie 7
rook b8 comes to mind rookie 7 rook b8
so black has a ton of moves uh if you
don't do anything as white specifically
black has tons of good shuffling moves
96 h5h4 rook d7 rook e8 they play
themselves again we are talking about
time advantages a very similar situation
24 minutes for favi alireza an hour and
in my opinion the easier moves to find
so at some point i wonder if avi decides
hey let's pull the brakes let's put
let's play knight c5 and start training
pieces off because i don't want to find
myself in a worse position down on time
remember we do have extra time at mu 40
but we're still 20 moves away from that
yeah to begin with and the move bishop
a2 for me peter is really an awkward
move to play because if you'd never
break with e4 that bishop on a2 i think
can't be a guy
i think we like we're selling it wrong i
think too is he is not playing for
advantage i think he's saying
uh in terms of
perhaps not being worse long term i need
the bishops to be still on the board
because if you if you imagine in this
position the bishop is actually coming
off and the rook's doubling on the e
file the knight on the five
and the double rooks on the e file put
so much pressure on the e3 pawn that you
you really do start imagining black
workers in the black black just in the
in the driver's seat yeah so i mean i
was trying to i was
trying to make overtime work for the
rook the rook being on a3 to cover the
the e3 square but like if we just
continue the line first right like i
take take i go another five the pawn
only three is already hanging actually
exactly you already have to make some
decisions as to how you're going to
protect it
doesn't
really feel like the way i wanted seven
rookie
play is extremely natural
the one weakness is on b7 where it can't
really be gotten at very very uh
successfully so exactly it's just a very
comfortable position for black so you
think bishop a2 is a move you play not
necessarily because you're
being optimistic or something like that
it's just that
the knight coming to f5 is actually too
disruptive i think i think it's it's a
defensive move weirdly
i don't think you enjoy putting the
bishop on a diagonal where like the only
way to justify it would be to play three
four and it really doesn't feel very
likely that you get a 3-4 to work in
this type of position because black is
just way way too prepared for it and
alejandra i really needed you to expand
upon
why you don't play knight e6 but you
play knight d7 the
computer engine were like what what what
you don't play knight e6 you mean in
this position you're knight five yeah
the engine wanted to go knight d7 right
it just thought that threading off all
of the knights would ease white's
position and kind of the same lines that
peter is saying perhaps black is the one
that's thinking about more than just
equality
thinking well let's keep some pieces on
the board let's pressure some pawns this
knight could go to f5 some point it does
like black a little bit the more you let
it think the more it thinks that black
is the one in the driver scene in this
position even after the move push up
knight takes bishop takes it already
gives a very solid minus 0.7 to
to the black piece and black pieces you
can imagine rookie 7 or k8 h4 bishop
somewhere even to c8 knight coming to f5
attacking this pawn on e3 again white's
position i'm not sure what the plan is
if you don't get e4 in and as you
mentioned e4
everything that
black owns is targeted towards e4 not
working and even when you get it in you
have these pawns you have to work with
so
perhaps you know black is actually just
better in this position and white is the
one that has no plan
wow and you had the
i took you away from the game that you
actually wanted to talk about which was
the wesley so versus shaq game what's
what's taken place
uh since our break the engines don't
really like the way the shack handled
the position after the move c4 bishop f5
i was advocating for the computer move
queen c7 which guarded
against move bishop b2 now shaq took a
couple of tempe to trade this pawn on a6
for this pawn on b4 but i'm not entirely
sure what he's gaining for it after a5
bishop e3 takes takes queen e7 uh again
black is attacking this pawn on before
it's become let's call it a weakness but
after the very logical move b5 which i
don't think he's played yet but the very
logical move b5 um i'm not sure why
this pawn which is now passed has and
does gain a lot of space for white what
black is planning to do against it
because if you're spending this much
time weakening it
i think your idea is going to target it
directly right but the more i see it the
more i think this pawn is just very
beautifully placed on b6 it will be
crushing a lot of black's position uh
you're going to run out i think i'm
keeping it on b5 for quite a bit because
i want to restrict the bishop on the
server
as possible yeah all right like my idea
here would be to play
prepare and play knight c3 and then
black really does not have very many
squares to look forward so the bishop b7
is just completely hamstrung by
by the pawn on b5
uh yeah it's so it's
i completely agree with everything you
know you're saying i mean i i understand
why opening up the a file for the rook
on e8 would be appealing to him but it
also spends perhaps time that he didn't
necessarily have and it did create a
passer for white which otherwise would
have been you know white would have had
to work to
uh to create an actual passer on the b
file i'm not sure i like this very much
i wanted to briefly touch on a game we
kind of i think all of us sort of wrote
off a little bit which was as very kind
of dry yeah this is the the other petrov
because it it probably will still be
very dry because uh white has options
but it's the mvl yeah the mvl the mvl uh
linear game but
is a very curious one uh
because we were discussing ways to kind
of
equalize dryly by trading the bishop of
five foreign and instead in year just
offers the pawn on d5
uh i think his point is knight h4 here
i think this is an actual i think this
is an actual pawn sacrifice i think he
wants to play knight h4 as opposed to
the bishop takes h2 check which i think
loses material i think like it's bad
strategically but i think it also just
loses material because yeah i take with
the king and i go knight d3 and i don't
think you
you actually have enough squares on the
fifth rank
to guard to guard the bishop i think i
go like b4 c4 before a4 and just i win
material here quite simply
so i i think his point is if knight
takes d5 happens he wants to go knight
h4
okay and use the fact that we are
overloading the bishop on f3 to actually
take it next move spoiling the structure
and then having another six knight of
three gfgf
and i want to i want this to be my first
absolutely egregious use of the word
martial compensation for something that
is not the martial
that's a very loose smartphone
compensation uh this is going to be like
it's always been a recurring theme
whenever uh whenever i talk about chess
but this is a like there is something
marshally about this marshally
this is a man who loves to be upon down
but let's jump over to bucharest and
we're joined with anastasia
what's what do you have her is anastasia
yeah hello again everyone and here we
are in bucharest so the games are still
continuing and while the players are
fighting on the boards we had a very
interesting press conference with gary
kasparov there were many journalists
many questions you can imagine there
were many political questions these days
and it was very interesting very
exciting press conference the hall was
full of people and i mean it was amazing
at the same time the plane hall is also
full of spectators and all of us are
following of course the first round
the players seem to be a little bit
nervous
as usually when you start the tournament
but otherwise everything goes smoothly
and i just want to say how happy i am
also to be here and to work with all of
you to see your faces your commentaries
it's great
thank you thank you anastasia anastasi
by the way uh was a very instrumental
when we're setting up a stream
in russian to come here and to st louis
and to help us with that uh so it's very
very nice to be working with her again
as well absolutely yeah
uh we didn't see by the way wesley so's
move b4 b5 and the more you looked at b4
b5 we like i liked it a lot i thought it
was very compelling instead wesley said
look you know what uh
i don't like the tension on the a file i
do want to play knight c5 i don't want
to necessarily allow a trade of rooks
i'll keep everything i keep my options
play rook b1 and uh you like this move
it's it's a restrained choice but i i
don't hate it all i think it's very
sensible i honestly i also want to say i
think if the knight goes anywhere it
goes to c3 i think we are not trading
pieces here i don't think it's in
white's best interests to try to trade
the way the knight on d7 it's not a
great piece
if it goes away from your seven if you
play knight of fate then i will
seriously consider going knight c5 but
as long as the knight is on d7 i would
much rather put my knight on on c3 i i i
tell you peter the more i look at it put
the bishop on d4 put the knight on c3
and you can go to sleep i mean the
position is just it's so he plays it
oh my goodness uh and alejandro you have
uh the uh mvl game as well you think
that's a
marshally compensation definitely not
because nvl didn't take the pawn this is
why i said it might still be very dry
because i thought xd5 wasn't happening
yeah knight xd5 did not happen actually
the computers liked it for white they
thought there is some compensation but
if it's enough black would still have to
prove it instead we have to move knight
g3 inviting some kind of complications
the engine's top move is rook d8 taking
advantage of the background uh threats
but let's take a look how it happens if
i start chopping things off knight takes
f4 is a very natural move uh the only
way to try to get an advantage here with
the white pieces is of course knight
takes f5 hits the bishop on d6 which is
defending the knight on f4 that's a
check that one's a piece but it also
attacks the pawn on g7 this forces a
reaction from the black pieces you could
go knight d3 rook d1 you got to defend
this rook somehow and after knight takes
c1 uh the knight is
it's trapped behind the truck it's kind
of trapped so you could go ahead and
take on g7 and the line continues
actually the move bishop f4 is playable
just defending the knight saying yes you
can grab my knight but it'll cost you an
exchange and apparently somehow the move
knight h5 is playable here this is as
people say alien chest to me
it prepares the moves g3 and eventually
f4 trapping the knight and it still
thinks that black is somehow okay this
might not be as dry as we expected it to
be there's still a lot of variations to
be calculated but dominguez does have
the more sane option of not allowing any
of this to happen to just go to rook de
8 first
take advantage of the backgrounds as i
mentioned and if the bishop comes out
let's say to e4 uh to e3 then you have
access to e4 it still thinks that white
has some
little bit of a pull because of the
placement of some of the pieces
specifically the pattern h5 can be
targeted with a move knight f5 later
when the bishops get traded so it still
thinks that white might be able to do a
little something something from this dry
end game but it's not much
why on earth do you play rook d8 to e8
and not
the rook that's not developed uh that is
a good question i don't know if it
actually matters not much okay
i mean
yeah development counts or not i guess
not uh queen f2 by the way in the game
of fabi we were wondering what fabi
would like to do yeah he continues sort
of shuffling and not committing to
anything exactly yeah q3 maybe also i
think it might be useful for us uh with
white to uh unpin the knight on f4 from
the queen on g5 for the future
absolutely i mean whenever we get in an
e4 we don't want to be in this pin so
queen f2
may be prepping queen g3 just getting
out of
but at the other hand
i think black is right h4 h4 is quite
telecraft here and yeah it seems it
seems very logical to continue along the
same path but not play yeah he's played
97 instead a move that we
spoke about when there was a knight on
c5 we haven't really considered playing
it
uh
in preparation for knight c5 but it
definitely makes some sense because the
knight on a4
you know if it doesn't land on c5 then
this entire maneuver has been sort of
wasted so agreed preparing for it in
advance makes
makes decent sense again the knight went
to f8 in order to release uh the kraken
and the bishop on c8 was kind of trapped
so knight going back to d7 uh b2 b4 i
mean i do want to bring my knight to c5
peter i mean i think it's like your idea
of queen g3 i mean now i play queen g3
of course
instead of b4
yeah
i mean one thing about this position is
everything we said about black
potentially being better all of this is
i think very much predicated on the
queen staying on the board any kind of
an endgame can basically never be better
for black at all because you're very
safely protecting the pawn on e3 with
the king on f2 right many like most of
the issues white potentially could have
in this position just completely
disappear if the queens come off because
the way in the kind of a classical kyle
boss structure the way
black occasionally gets in front
is by launching some kind of an attack
in in the center and on the on the king
side and those things don't really
happen very much once the queens come
off right which is why i think you're
you're you're pointing out queen g3 is
very relevant but i think it doesn't
force the queens to come off i think we
quite happily go queen e7 here as black
and then perhaps go h4 and return it to
g5 later
and this is why my eyes kind of lit up
when you played before rookie seven
because after after before rookie seven
i think queen g3 has a much better shot
of actually forcing the queens off
before
you yeah you played rookie seven here
and this is where i started ah this is
why it got you excited yeah i i thought
now i play queen g3 and maybe and maybe
queen f6 is such an awkward move to make
like it's i think it's a much more
awkward square than e7 i can easily see
that i'm falling for a tactic yeah some
some kind of a tactic might have been
along those diagonals okay well we'll
definitely keep an eye on this uh
quickly let's go around the horn just
for a second to see
what has transpired in this very awkward
game uh between levon and richard
this
cagey
equilibrium continues being maintained
by by richard he once again refuses to
win the pawn on e4 here going 97
suggesting perhaps that he wants to go
uh e65 or perhaps even maybe put the
knight on f6 and
just increase the pressure and the
knight on b6 was the one poor light
piece black hat so
improving improving the position of the
knight on b6 definitely makes a ton of
sense to me night these i still i still
kind of like this for black i don't know
if it's necessarily great but i if i had
to pick a side here i'm very very
comfortable picking black in this place
one other thing
i mean you say the knight on b6 not that
great and i'll go with you on that one
it did however protect the square c4 and
now that knight has moved away from the
square c4 you do have to watch 365
though like tactics probably might work
out for black somewhere around here
because you i mean although d5 and then
e5 e6 might be it could suddenly become
like an absolute slugfest where we we
will have to give up this exchange on f2
but we don't now have a very promising
passer on
uh only six it does look like a very but
i guess i i guess also after queens
after bishop c4
we don't have to you know crazy do
anything knee jerk just go queen e7
prepare the same break
exactly for the moment can i
again g5 annoys me every single time but
maybe
but maybe i can just go queen e8 there
maybe i can go queen eight to the
beginning of it from the start yeah
g5 yeah uh i do feel somehow this rook
on f2 is not
my favorite piece it's it's
it's weird i i i
i i'm confused it's one of my favorite
words again it definitely describes
describes this game so far it's a very
weird game uh
what do you have for us alejandro uh
just a couple of looks at what has
happened in the last couple of moves in
some games knight d7 is a kg move it
does prepare the move knight f6 it does
prefer queen e7 and e5 but it does seem
that it gives levon a choice as well as
how to continue the move bishops before
certainly playable the move bishop g5
immediately is playable you can even
take on f5 taking advantage of the fact
that this knight is not landing on d5 on
the very next move so a lot of different
options here for levon 30 minutes for
him 37 for his opponent still plenty of
time in the game between nepo and deck
very very different scenario
certainly not gonna get mated because
there are no queens on the board i was
told in my ear by the producers this is
a wild wild game this is exactly the
opposite of a wild wild game as after
the move h5 queen d4 this queens were
forced off the board and after queen
takes pawn takes bishop h6 rook eight we
have the position on the board it does
seem that in this ending game black has
some things that he's suffering about
this pawn on b7 is difficult to defend
this pawn on d4 will probably fall at
some point but he
is do still you do still sometimes get
mated in these types of end games
he might i can go four or five here and
i think that the question will sort of
remain whether whether your king is
entirely safe but yeah definitely this
is an improvement for black in terms of
in particular in terms of in particular
the practical side he's down to 15
minutes and uh
defending an endgame where threats will
be more sort of more telegraphed and
easier to parry and he still has his
extra pawn to to fall back on here i
think definitely this is an improvement
for for bogdan and uh
well the queen trade has to just come as
enormous sense of relief even if it's
still an awkward or difficult position
that queen trade just makes life so much
more bearable i want to say and again
absolutely
time will be a factor sorry alejandro
and perhaps because of this move uh
queen d4 being a threat the engine here
was not a huge fan of the move h5 was
extremely subtle at how i wanted to
continue the move rook b5 was actually
its preferred way on queen whoops let's
get this on the board and if queen d4
you can do something similar you can
take take but the pawn on d5 will always
be hanging you don't have to take it
immediately you can also play the move
bishop g4 unfortunately bishop b2 is
currently being threatened and that is
the main issue that if you kick out my
rook which actually is the top engine
move surprisingly uh the move a6
allowing your queen to be e3 to be
captured both bishop d2 and bishop b2 uh
work i actually did that on the other
way around bishop d2 allows queen d4 but
the end game is no fun and on bishop b2
you can take on d3 take on d3 pawn takes
b5 and maybe this looks lost from a
human eye especially with the move e6
coming queen e5 coming on the long
diagonal the engines don't care they
think a6 takes queen e5 but you still
have to move bishop f6 so all is good
they like white a little bit more
because aquino is a queen but it doesn't
think that it's such a huge advantage
and this would have been a tough one to
find at least i would assess this as a
tough move to find for dag the move rook
b5 would have been kger and i think it
would have put more practical problems
on the young
player over the move h5 which was a
little too direct and now we have an end
game in which f4 yes it's on the board
but if f45 doesn't kill
then and uh as you can see there is
there's great potential for lots and
lots of material uh coming off the board
which once again
improves uh improves the situation
immensely yeah you can maybe even uh in
in some of these positions you can uh
sort of bite the bullet and just make
some kind of a quiet move like b7 b6 so
that b7 isn't hanging and if f5 comes i
just trade everything on the 5 go rook
ac8
and yeah it looks scary but if there is
no immediate made you request
we traded off a lot of material
we put some pressure on the c2 pawn and
so on but
for now we'll take a short short
commercial break and we will be back
with the continuation of round one of
the bucharest grand chess tour excellent
thank you peter
[Music]
if you have kids you already know st
louis has a ton of fun stuff for
families to do like the magic house or
the science center and if you really
want to be a stellar parent come see all
the new stuff there is to discover at st
louis union station with a new mirror
maze light shows and the 20-story high
st louis wheel it's enough to make any
parent feel like a star
st lou is always exploring
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a st louis public radio journalists most
precious possession isn't a notepad
camera
microphone or recording device their
most precious possession
is credibility
a journalist's work revolves around the
truth
finding it
verifying it
and reporting it
great journalists work hard to find the
facts and put those facts into context
examining all the arguments and
including differing opinions
amplifying fascinating voices from our
community
telling captivating stories
offering facts that may have been
omitted
we work every day to earn your trust for
news turn to st louis public radio
[Music]
when you visit st louis you'll probably
want to watch the cardinals or the blues
what about after the game
heading back to the hotel would be a
major error
instead boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the blues
their name at the national blues museum
broadway oyster bar or even the
legendary blueberry hill so whether you
love the cardinals the blues or the
blues come play with us
and you guys know i can't play this
right
st lou is always exploring
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back
welcome back indeed as we
uh jump right into to day one uh game
one round one of our grand chess tour
from bucharest let's go around the horn
and take a look at the five
games uh we'll start with the game
between fabi
and ali raja after the move knight d7
h2h4 queen
f6 b2b4 queen d6 on the board knight c5
and i'm feeling more or less that the
position's rather balanced at this at
this point i
like white space i don't like the fact
that his pawn is on e3
uh yeah i think uh
h4 was a very good decision by firebase
sort of stopping the uh the potential
gain of space by by le reza on the
king's side perhaps you could have age
four this is where we come back to the
decision of 21 not to play h5h for
himself for foreign perhaps he didn't
like something tactically because h5
was played on the previous move
seemingly with the intention
and then he didn't do it anyway but yeah
now it seems like fabi definitely
stabilized he he got h4 in uh securing
the knight on the f4 from potential as
well perhaps yeah and he got before in
knight c5 in just in time so
uh it looks yeah as you said it looks
very balanced black can play rookie
seven let's say i don't know knight f6
or b8
yeah and uh
a maneuvering game yeah i think pushing
e34 is
extremely unrealistic in most cases it
seems like but also black will not have
very much in the way of a constructive
planet so
when we left it uh in the game between
lavonne and richard
uh report
the players were playing this kind of
cagey back and forth
chess
but knight d7 really is going to
precipitate a very important decision
because takes takes and knight f6
is going to force white uh to make a
stand in the center lavon said let's do
it
e4 e5 knight came back to
to b6 eyeballing the d5 square king g2
h7 h6
and what did you call it the fancy
fancy play syndrome fancy play syndrome
we've got some fancy play going on yeah
these are these are two of the people i
think in this field who will be accused
of it the most
over the course of the next couple of
weeks because they they both are very
much excellent i'm looking forward to
you know practitioners of that of that
art and uh how is the art being
practiced in real terms whites for
choice blacks for choice what do you
think about balance i think i think it's
become more to my eyes it's become a
little bit mobile i think probably black
had
ways to be more forceful early and now
it feels like maybe they won't stabilize
to a degree i'm still picking black but
the bishop on g6 is
back to being not very bright right if
you if you could imagine
like fe4 before included at any point
earlier this bishop would have been a
monster now and
i think this is also why they won't play
the 45 just something like
fvfe97 just
just to show a bad line a sample bad
line that
something like that different difference
is quite pronounced here yeah this
bishop is suddenly
like as you said it's a monster whereas
the current position less so let me just
flash back to the current position the
bishop uh blocked on g6 all right uh
continuing with this game uh
yeah interestingly uh
between of the two moves which preserved
the pawn on b7 in these types of end
games uh bogdan chose rp8 over b6 which
is somewhat surprising to me for me too
because it feels like the rook
will kind of really want to be on c8
very big time yeah big time and so why
why aren't we playing b6 speaking of
very soon like
right on the next move right about now
yeah yeah you might want to be thinking
that if the pawn were on b6 we would be
trading and bringing or at least
calculating it very seriously yeah
exactly we might even still be doing it
uh here but allowing rook takes b7 is
going to be a major
major by the way diac under seven
minutes as he's still facing
an awkward uh
decision i mean exactly ruby 3g iii is a
lethal lethal idea here yeah the road
yeah the rover 47 minutes for yon and uh
he looks to be in the driver's seat also
looking to be in the driver's seat is
wesley so
yeah in his game with shaq i think we
has gone slightly off the rails for
shakira it feels to me exactly
especially with the inclusion of the
move g6
now when you just compare the bishops in
in this bishops of opposite color
position i mean how can we not help but
like i think he goes knight g7 either
immediately or maybe in the next one or
two was because he needs to challenge
this knight this bishop on d4 and it
doesn't really if he if it ends up
costing him the g5 pawn but
but trading every single light piece off
i think you snap take that right
you're extremely happy about that
outcome because if you continue just
giving white time to develop you will
just get mated over the light squares
eventually or the b pawn will decide the
game one of the two exactly so you need
to be you need to start taking somewhat
dramatic measures here
i i like the the decision to play knight
g7 very much now finally our fifth and
final position
is this
again a kind of a cagey game that's
going on between lanier and
mvl
he did choose the move rook on h8 by the
way and it feels like that move has
equalized it honestly i think i can
maybe specifically after bish b3 i can
maybe answer the question you addressed
to alejandra earlier why rook he8 is
maybe slightly less precise than rook g8
because if you if you play let's let's
let's sure let's put the move hp3 on
as it happened in the game actually
hasn't happened in the game sorry bishop
b3 i think
my
idea here would be to play bishop to xf4
because i would like to you know trade
trade away as many light pieces as
possible but after knight takes f5
bishop takes e3 and let's say f takes e3
uh g7 is hanging
and the only real real way of protecting
it is to play rogue g8 right
removing the rook from the e file right
again so if you played rook g88 15 i
would play rook hg8 here and i would
already be prepared to play knight g67
nice uh pushing away the knight from f5
so i think this might be a somewhat
inaccurate way to play it which as a
kind of a uh you know all of these
things flow from each other he
probably because of that chose to play
knight h4 and now the knight of five
knight of five and i assume bishop d2
knight e4 works if 94 works i take all
of all of it back and black is
completely fine
uh
in general i'm somewhat reluctant to
allow yeah first of all there's bishop
g4 tactics but even
simply the the structure change of
bishop to ac4 and gta xe4
often worries me in these types of
positions because sometimes this pawn
becomes
a target a liability and a target for
white to play against but in this
particular position i look at it and i
don't really see the white light pieces
aren't really positioned well enough to
create any kind of pressure against it
so maybe it's fine
and there we have it uh our walk around
the hall and let's go to romania what do
you have for us christian
anastasia thank you uh yes sir yes we i
actually want to talk a little bit about
trends uh in chess especially at the
highest level because now we see quite
an interesting uh situation in the game
between fabiano and alireza and actually
in another game that's been happening at
the top level as well today and uh i was
shocked because i usually see players
following trends one two days later and
i'm saying to myself sure back in the
days it used to take maybe a week couple
of weeks until it was in print nowadays
of course you have the databases and
everything that comes along with that
but these players actually are paying
the same exact game today and that is
the game between fabiano and ali reza
and with this quite novel idea a4 a4 has
only been played twice and not
necessarily at the highest level another
game
that is being playing is being played
today is in the tempest sigma tournament
the high level tournament in a game
between van forest and michael adams and
they had exactly the same position a4
followed by knight to h5 exchanges rook
to a3 knight to a4 at this point it was
ali reza that played this move rook to
b8 and adams play the move bishop to e6
quite interesting to see how these
trends are developing we understand that
they have the engines and probably
they're analyzing a lot of similar
things whenever they work at home i
really uh liked this situation and it
was quite novel for me as well how about
you anastasia yes i mean it was such a
surprise and it's the only good thing i
can say they don't play at the same
plane hall otherwise i don't know what
the arbiters will do changing the tables
moving them to the other rooms i don't
know it would be really a disaster so um
i also wanted to share some insight yes
i mean from yesterday i was talking ab
with uh richard trappert and uh he said
that he's starting the marathon actually
i mean he's going to play all possible
events
in the row like starting from here then
following wars so he will go also to
norway chess and then like it was not
enough he will also play in the
candidates tournament right i mean so
what do you think about it i mean is it
possible to do something like that so
much just for a richer report and i know
two of you at least have played in the
candidates so what is your opinion on
that did you like to play a lot of games
uh in preparation for the candidates or
did you like take more of a resting
approach before candidates i
thank you christian
for me personally uh i have a kind of a
very similar story in 2013 i between i
think march and june i was at home for
like seven days total
but
i think i would have done something
different if if the tournaments were in
the other order because i think it
started with me playing in the london
candid candidates the the tournament
that uh you know started magnus on on
his path to becoming world champion
and then i played a number of very
strong round robins afterwards all
pretty much flowing
[Music]
one to another
but the candidates was clearly the one
that that sort of mattered the most to
me and i think i probably would have
decided to skip some of them if they
were resulting in me playing the
candidates like three months in
uh whereas richard actually is doing
exactly exactly that he's playing it's
not gonna be three months but he is
playing a number of events one after
each other right uh culminating in him
playing the candidates uh
one of i think one of the sort of
biggest unresolved kind of mysteries of
chess life is how to
uh
get to the important events in your in
your career in the best possible shape
and people take all kinds of differing
approaches to that and i don't think
anybody really knows i don't know have
you ever figured out whether you play
better after being properly warmed up or
if you play better
fresh after i don't know two months
break just spend thinking about chess
perhaps preparing because for me
there's just like
there's no rhyme or reason to it right i
i've done some good things in my chess
career
following
large breaks i've done some good things
at the end of long stretches of of play
and
you know alternatively i've bombed
completely
thinking i'm in good form like i've done
all the right things like i've got
myself in shape i've you know i've been
you know eating eating well working on
chairs like i've i feel good and then
nothing works at all over the board so
it just
i
i don't i i know that i don't have an
answer but i also it feels to me nobody
really has an answer still well in in
my case uh i simply didn't have the
choice and my two candidates uh in
montpelier in 1985 and against
the spielman and the candidates matches
there just weren't the events that there
are today
uh you're talking about richard rapport
going from the grand chess tour
uh bucharest warsaw
madrid then the candidates and gosh
knows what comes next the field cups and
things like that we just didn't have
these kinds of things and i remember
very vividly
the
the uh prescription advice of bod
vinegar oh yeah you play 60 games
55 games 56 games a year pardon me uh
you know
precisely this number no more no less
and that was optimum and uh today i
think that the players are absolutely
forced to play a lot more absolutely now
does that
mean that they're more tired or did i
don't know these guys play really really
really good i mean for me
magnus carlson is playing non-stop and
is
his i think everybody's playing accuracy
is just phenomenal yeah everybody's
playing non-stop and it has to do not
only with the schedule of events we have
now chess of course being so much more
popular and becoming an esport both at
the same time but also rapid time
controls coming into play allowing more
and more tournaments to be scheduled one
after another to the point where players
are actually having to make tough
choices do i want to play in the rapid
chess championship they want to commit
to the grand chess tour what about my
candidates prep what's going to happen
with the grand prix system there's so
many things that go into the minds of
the top players nowadays that perhaps
weren't really available before exactly
and i feel a lot of them are just
playing on inertia one tournament after
another without having the real time to
think about what they should be doing
and of course richie going from this to
warsaw to norway chess to the candidates
seems suicidal but let's see what
actually happens in madrid to me that
would be too much just i don't i would
not advise anybody to have your fourth
tournament in a row yeah be the
candidates exactly but here we are and
of course richie never shies away from a
fight let's go back into chess a little
bit we do have updates in a couple of
games of course this one is important
let's take a look at the fobby big game
because alireza played a move that i
didn't think was very good but the
engines hated it a lot more than i did
uh we got to this position with the
queen on d6 knight on c5 and i was
assuming that at some point this knight
will trade itself on c5 perhaps not
today perhaps not the next move but down
the line this knight on c5 has to
disappear i would think a move like
rookie 7 is quite normal in this
position the engines were even
considering the move b6 which i would
never consider but they think tactically
it resolves the problems of the position
uh but otherwise i played the move
knight f6 which i didn't quite fully
understand because i don't know where
the knight is going this one on f3 is
doing a great job at already restricting
the knight it can't go to d5 obviously
it can't go to g4 i'm not sure what the
knight is doing there and also
importantly it allows this slight
tactical issue of this queen getting
life the queen on g3 is much better
spotted than on f2 and it has an
annoying trick this knight takes h5 is
actually an idea in this position taking
advantage of the the fact that the queen
is undefended and the knight on h5 would
defend the queen on g3 so it sets up a
trick the queen actually had to cede
some space goes back to d8 and
immediately five it goes queen g5 and
you can start seeing that the last
couple of moves must be favoring the
white side in this position suddenly the
move e4 is coming into fruition in some
positions because if the bishop opens up
sometimes the move knight takes g6 will
even come on the board clearly this
piece is the major pieces that black has
have gotten a little bit more passive
the rook on b8 wanted to be on e7 not
quite on ba the queen was already on d6
in a good square it was forced to move
back so certainly favi making a little
bit of progress in his position the
engine
really likes his position gives him a
clear advantage i don't think that it's
so relevant but remember he has only
eight minutes in his clock for the
remaining 14 moves another game that i
wanted to show uh put your attention on
is the simplifications that happened in
the game between nepamyachi and bogdan
dayak
and this position after the move rook b8
you guys mentioned it rook b8 is really
weird it feels wrong somehow but nepa
didn't take full advantage of it here
the move f5 was definitely the best move
but after pawn takes f5 here i believe
that the world championship challenger
of the previous match missed his chance
the move rook f3 nice the engines
thought were just it was a much better
move and it's a little bit of a cagey
one of course the threat is clear um
it's not a killing blow you could
actually play b6 and somehow not die
immediately but of course you want to
prevent rook g37 is coming and in bishop
f8 the point is that you go back to f4
whoops
allow me to do this and e6 is coming uh
hitting this rook on b8 which is
awkwardly posted and if you just play
the move bishop e6 trying to prevent me
from doing this then after check king
eight shade the engine plays a very
difficult move to find in this position
and perhaps this is the reason the
network didn't find this is that the
move h6
bishop threading bishop g5 bishop f6
meeting this
with rook g7 and this is where the
engine just goes a little bit alien-like
in a absolutely beautiful sequence
bishop f8 hitting the rook get out of my
position this engine says no
i'm going to play g4
and if you find this move from afar
well
i think that's a little questionable
it's a full exchange sacrifice but the
two pawns on e5 and f5 apparently are
more than enough composition then you're
thinking that white is actually for
choice in this position i think this is
an impossible sequence to find uh very
logical instead to just take on f5 and
even though bishop c5 is playable in
this position the solution that they are
found give up the pawn immediately with
the move d3 is absolutely engine
approved the point is e5 is weak as well
so when you go bishop c5 check the rook
will take on e5 retaining the pawn
advantage
white retains some trumps in the
position but is it enough for an
advantage the computers say no that
being said it is 35 minutes against four
minutes for black so that might be uh
trouble for the romanian player so far
in the position however it seems that
he's solving most of his problems
wonderful there we have that we have jan
in a very customary i think i missed
something uh uh look right yeah yeah is
that move
d3 kind of like rock them backwards a
little bit uh
otherwise rook f3 really is nice um
i wanted to
ask you a little bit
because it goes hand in glove with what
you were saying about
too much play not enough play are you
are you getting yourself informed but
you also need
to research to come up with some social
ideas and anastasia and christian are
saying right now today remarkably enough
in this tournament in sweden in malmo
uh the same opening has been content i i
did want to say that uh
i'm not really sure about the state of
that particular union but yeah uh
mickey did work with fabi
at some point i think candidates of last
yeah so 20 20 candidates but not he's
playing he's playing this with black and
white is playing this with white so
perhaps it's not
uh-huh but i did want to kind of throw
an additional additional ingredient into
the mix there so okay good that maybe
it's not maybe it's not uh
such a you know
outlandish coincidence but
in general i absolutely agree with with
christian i remember i had those
conversations with my uh with my uh
coach who said that basically
uh when he was active as a chess player
which was like 70s 80s
uh
if you had a novelty you could
legitimately expect sort of you know eat
off it for like half a year or two
exactly it was going to be the
informants only yeah twice a year so you
could play a novelty three times if
you're lucky yeah and also you in
particular like in the old soviet times
there were people who had like pet
openings
who legitimately would ask uh organizers
of events to
like not publish their scoresheets right
and then it's just completely gone
nobody knows what you're doing exactly
and you can and you can play like i have
a particular name in mind which will not
be known in the west but there was like
a particular international master in uh
leningrad in those times who played the
philidor and a very specific very very
dodgy philidor right
and
but it was tricky and he didn't know
what you were doing if he found a new uh
kind of a new wrinkle uh to survive with
black like he could actually do that for
for up to a year until people caught up
and now everything is live and that
evening it will get analyzed and refuted
so yeah life has moved on well but that
goes to the whole concept of like if
you're playing too much
you don't even get a chance to reflect
into well research in this case but but
on that point i wanted to say that
uh these are you know sort of the
absolute top professionals who have
teams working for them yeah so
they they do have an advantage of
actually you know being able to delegate
and i think the game may have is this
already three times it's going to be
it might be three times if alireza goes
for the move queen d6 and five who
repeats with the move queen g3 i don't
think that there was much of an
incentive for favi to continue with the
time situation he has yeah i think and
specifically that alaresa's position has
deteriorated
so it does feel like both players might
be okay with this result queen g5 asked
alireza if you want to draw because
after queen d6 he would have to accept
it if avi stops the clock and claims the
threefold repetition with the queen g3 i
see and s45b i think it's sort of
exclusively to do with the six minutes
on the clock because
his position by this point is very safe
and clearly at least a little bit better
maybe not much but at least a little bit
better
that was something else i wanted to say
too is this idea of do you play a lot
in the old days uh
truthfully the western players just
didn't have
the financial resources the sponsorships
that were necessary to have
a staff a coaching staff or in fact a
single coach you know this was very
difficult so you were doing a lot of
research on your own but like you say
you know if if i've got a mickey adams
if i've got an alejandro uh you know
working in the shadows and keeping me
informed that's a completely different
uh
situation than
what we do what we do in the shadows
yeah exactly um
ex what do you have for us uh oh
you're just looking around nothing
pretty nothing pretty i was taking a
look at the game between wesley saw and
shocked me around because if anything is
going to be decisive this one has the
most potential this is all wesley all
day long and i think the position keeps
getting worse and worse for men it's
true that these two connected past pawns
in the center are theoretically great if
they start rolling they will never move
from this square this bishop on b7 is
trash the spawn on the b file will get
all the way to b6 at some point and the
thing is which pieces do you trade if
you start trading this knight this
bishop on d4 is gonna very importantly
start hitting the pawn on f6 you will
have to move this pawn on f6 at some
point or you're gonna have to dedicate
uh heavy pieces to defend this pawn
neither of which is a pretty sight if
you move the pawn you will eventually
have to deal with the battery on the
diagonal it might just kill you but if
you dedicate too many pieces to uh
defending this pawn then i'm gonna pass
this one i'm gonna play rookie one i'm
gonna penetrate on the queen side where
is black's counter play where is black's
plan i just don't see it this more than
perhaps it's not a lost position i'm
sure that an engine will hold it against
most humans but it's so ugly to play
this position with with black it's
definitely not shock's style either to
just sit down passively in a slightly
worse strategical end game but this is
not slightly worse i think this is just
almost almost lost clearly worse for him
yes strategically just feels terrible i
think the the only real question there
is how do you make enough enough of a
progress because i i assume the knights
are coming off and then we have a
situation where
we all absolutely i mean everything
alejandro said is true the position is
ugly to look at the bishop on b7 is
horrible the the white pawn will be on
b5 and potentially b6 later even though
i once again i
kind of like keeping it on b5 to leave
no squares for the bishop exactly
and you can connect it with you know
creating some some threats on the king
side but with the limited material left
on the board the the hope here is
basically that you can kind of greenly
defend it for long enough to
uh
to to survive but yeah it's it's really
really not great for shakhriar and a
beautiful word there to describe the
circumstance grim
it's simply you know you sometimes you
have these gritty defenses but this this
one looks really grim and the play is
all on white side i want to just uh by
the way
i'm used to saying richard as in richard
did you pronounce richard a little bit
differently well i think i think
i've had yeah i've had this this
conversation early on there with uh when
we were doing some of the tournaments he
was playing in and i think
if if we are to
uh to be closer closer to the hungarian
pronunciation has to be reheard or i
think he very much doesn't mind richie i
think it's richard that is sort of you
know quote unquote incorrect because
that wouldn't be
that wouldn't be how it's pronounced in
uh in hungary but my understanding might
be
might be incomplete or just it works
rishi works really well for me okay
let's uh let's jump into the game of
lavon and richie when we left it
h7h6 had been
uh black's choice and queen v3 okay
i had a moment ago tried to play bishop
c4 but i definitely like this bishop
uh dropback defending the pawn bishop e3
i think both players are just still
struggling with
trying to find the optimal squares for
their pieces
yeah there it
uh
wow okay that is
uh
that's throwing down the gauntlet that's
a real challenge yeah that's uh very
much an indication that uh richie
doesn't doesn't really want a quiet game
here and it looks a bit outlandish at
first glance because you know h file is
now opened and of the two kings the one
on the age file is the black one not the
white one exactly but he will play i
guess king g7 rook h8 quite quickly and
uh putting any kind of pressure on the
pawn on g5 is difficult and a 504
might
maybe even already be a threat in some
positions depending on what white does
because
king g1 is a is a very interesting reply
by by levon immediately because you
mentioned f5 f4 or so maybe sometimes
when you bring your rook
to either the h file or g file you make
room for the bishop
um
look i love creative play come on i mean
you know big big ball but isn't this
going
like beyonce
g5 like
well he needs to do something uh i think
the issue is uh if you if we go back to
the position we'll say before like this
question it looks perfectly healthy for
black and white but i mean you need to
find progress and i'm i'm like 95
solves all of white's problems for them
right because white very happy trades
uh there is no longer any issues within
the center
rook fc2 exists the bishop.f1 now has a
square on b5
i don't know if white is better but why
definitely no longer it's like a relief
yeah so you keep the tension you play
and move like for example
everybody continues shuffling as well i
don't know exactly what what the shuffle
the preferred shuffle here is but yeah
some shuffling will be done i guess
exactly but the move g7 g5 it's sort of
like okay you're willing to open up the
king side but to whose advantage exactly
and the black king as you say it's like
it's the one sitting on the h-file not
too sure about the move king g1 by the
way but kg7 has been played if we could
play queen b3 d2 here that would have
been a good move but yeah
uh yeah rook h2 for now levon is clearly
saying that yeah i'm worried about the
rook landing on the h file so i'm i'm
getting my rook there first to kind of
preempt the potential
threats
uh black might have now
when you play the move g5 as black
you're also saying that
you know
besides the fact you're not playing for
a friendly draw i mean you're you're
saying that maybe i'm going to be
playing for the move f5 f4
um
again as i'm i'm very skeptical of what
black is doing you feel
that it's not bad i'm not sure it's
great but i also don't think it's that
bad because we haven't actually if you
think about it we haven't actually
committed
that much we can play queen e7 here for
instance light and then rocket shade
and even like i was talking about qb3 g2
ideas right
even let's say if i if i make a passing
move here and this happens
quintile pretty much always can be met
by king g6
uh
that's what i mean too your king is yeah
but it's it's reasonably safe on g6 as
well and uh yeah it's it's a strange
situation where
we've opened the age file but we're not
really giving mape we're also not
getting mated but alejandro has
something to say about the petrov yes
indeed well this game is about to be
over we did see that mind
had perhaps missed a tremendously
difficult thing to find there with the
sacrifices but as we see on the board
there is a very powerful pawn on c2 and
that is forcing white hand you don't
have a choice but to give the perpetual
with bishop g7 and either bishop f6 or
h6 on the next move but you can't create
any threats all of black's pieces are
securely defended and if you move that
work on c1 white will not have a
perpetual any longer and
the spawn will eventually promote and
that's why we see the handshake
as our first result of the tournament is
a draw between these two players and
well by the way big relief for
dick because he had no time yeah no time
left but he found just about enough
resources d4d3
was very nice very very timely indeed
and did we see also a result in the
fobby game as you were mentioning there
was a three three-move repetition
it is a three-fold repetition but i
guess nobody claimed it because
halleris is still on the board he could
have claimed the draw with the move
queen g3 but uh for some reason he
didn't it is up to alireza now he could
just end the game by just pressing the
stop button on the clock
but
uh let's see if he decides to do so
because five did think a little bit
before playing the move queen g3 and
fell down to four minutes wow has it
ever happened to you that both players
refused we've seen we've seen some
really some really bizarre
i think these days mainly it happens in
tournaments where there is like a
cut-off for
uh
for a potential draw for and people also
don't particularly want to call the
arbiter right so let's say let's say you
can make draws off the move 30. right
but your repetition starts on move 21.
so instead of making three repetitions
you make like seven you go to
30 just so that you're just so that you
don't call the arbiter no right but
basically if you if you if you make it
last until move 30 you can just sign
this questions there and don't bother
any of the officials right
but yeah it's it's kind of curious
because it seems like there is a little
bit of a you know let's assert dominance
games been going on yeah
they know they will be playing each
other for you know the foreseeable
future i don't even talk about the
candidates here i mean they clearly will
be playing each other
for the next i don't know five ten years
they're both young enough
uh
so nobody wants to be the one to say
yeah i don't like this i want i want to
get it over with and
there's this little bit of an interplay
here of you know who will be the one to
actually stop the clock and say yeah
this is a draw my my favorite story on
that one was it was a game between uh
john vanderville
who was white against anatoly karpov the
world champion and karpov had this uh
zaitsev
in his repertoire rook e8 knight g5 rook
f8 knight back to f3 and they played a
four
move repetition before uh john continued
the game
and it was just great and i said well
what were you doing john he said i was
getting closer to the time control
here
i i once i once uh did that in a junior
event i was playing against somebody
with black i wasn't 100 score at the
time and i was playing somebody who
i thought was a good player but i still
kind of fancied it a little bit and i i
was i just was my only opening against
lonnie four in those days pretty much
and i played the zaitsev and
he kind of needed to beat me so i
assumed it wouldn't happen and then
and then he just went 95 night of three
and
i
repeated three times and instead of
claiming i continued repeating and he
also didn't claim
and then i played 97 and just continued
playing
and i
instead of repeating it right and i won
the game and
was sort of happy with with the entire
thing but was
i think
he was not that impressed but yeah here
we do have another repetition
uh in the game between uh fabi and ali
reza as we have two results both drawn
and um
well uh
it's kind of funny that
for me at least that fabi was the one
who got into time trouble in this game
when he was the one playing a4 a5 rook
a3 and seemed like he knew what he was
doing only it took him a lot of time
peter
but first let's jump to bucharest as we
have a christian with napo
thank you yasser yes we are indeed here
with janna pumneyashi after a very
hard-fought uh draw against the
youngster bogdan daniel deck jan first
of all tell us you're back in bucharest
what are your initial impressions about
the torment the organization and the
opening ceremony tell us a little bit
about your first couple of days here in
bucharest
well now it takes a little bit longer to
to reach
to europe from russia yes so it was
quite quite a journey
uh istanbul uh so and yeah yesterday the
opening ceremony was as usually you know
undeservingly long
uh so but uh at least i mean of course
the assignment was fun
so i
didn't really have any time to have some
some let's say rest but uh on the other
hand i had like half a year rest after
my last classical game yeah so that's um
that's not a good excuse at least
and
yeah it's it's always fine it's uh it's
always nice to
see audience and it's especially nice
that here are no
covet restrictions so it's
surely pleases
you started off with the white pieces
against the lowest rated player you know
the event what was your strategy going
into this game just play a normal game
and
i guess
i would say
i think uh
bogdan has somewhat like
26 70 yet but he's only
20 years old so that's
pretty i'm pretty much sure we will soon
see him uh crossing 2700 marks so i
wouldn't say like
i wouldn't call him let's say some sort
of a big underdog here so he's very nice
gym without revealing too much how do
you assess his general style do you feel
he's more of a tactical player more of a
positional player how do you uh analyze
him i think he's through learning still
learning excellent let's get right into
the game it felt like uh you surprised
him in the opening despite him uh
playing uh the petrov but i'm sure you
had some residual knowledge from uh some
uh
preparation a few months ago now tell us
a bit about this position it felt like
the first move that kind of threw you
off was this move queen to e7
well uh
i guess uh
normal movies bishop is saying here but
okay queen g7 is a little bit artificial
now so here i wasn't sure like if i
should um i don't know
go for some
i don't know find few precise moves to
get some big advantage because queen e7
uh
in my opinion looks a little bit ugly
yeah so basically it never protects you
from a 45 and strategically the position
is
is not so great yeah but uh
somehow it probably gave me
you know
such a massive choice which uh that that
i couldn't uh you know handle
and i feel like you're kind of playing
the right moves uh a4
okay here of course queen d4 is topical
it's it's very nice idea so after queen
d4 my uh i think the end game is really
nice for white yeah so especially if i
trade off let's say dark square bishops
but okay queen d2 i guess could also be
played so it's not such a brilliant move
but why not but here i guess
yeah rugby one uh like probably
uh
probably castle wasn't also
you know good enough so
i think this queen on a5 will quickly
get into trouble if black goes to the
queen side yeah something like queen e2
bishop d2 or something
so it's not such a safe place for lex
queen but i think what i did was also
more or less uh
you know smart until my move queen of
four supreme force uh
24 is just a miscalculation and a very
interesting moment uh was at this point
did you spot this idea with rook to b5
and what was your assessment well
actually i was so you know so
disappointed with myself after i let the
c54 idea appear so i thought like all
right probably like
you know more or less solved uh the
initial problems but yeah as it seems uh
this was
a smart move here rugby fight well
perhaps after queen to b2 you have to
sacrifice the queen and
this position and i was wondering
whether
maybe i'm trying to go for e6 yeah so
here just open up things
and uh this
doesn't look too too brilliant for black
but yeah of course if i would um if i
would
see this idea i would surely
fall into it
and after that when did you feel was the
critical moment where he managed to
finally equalize well somehow i guess i
just underestimated my position a little
bit because okay this uh you know f5 uh
gf okay g5 was a surprise for me so i
wanted to play let's say bishop b5 for
rook f3
but then okay uh i couldn't really see
like uh what am i going to do how am i
going let's say to play on forum so i
decided to play bishop f5 and take a
draw and this probably was a little bit
premature but
uh yeah maybe it was you know a little
bit uh the impression of the
few
a few few few moves and um you know
there is um
probably this line is said to be very
jewish and maybe you know studying it a
little bit from the black side you know
uh gave
a few false impressions about how solid
black
in fact is but okay here i believe here
maybe here yeah just
okay probably probably bishop takes a
five was more more accurate move but
then okay after exchange
i would get some slight advantage in the
end game
uh yeah but uh of course uh of course uh
there was you know
um some push at this point yeah okay
here it looks like some nice rocking
game yes so if such a bad king on each
agent and a lot of weaknesses also
should i believe more or less than
ending into a draw but uh it is quite
depressing absolutely well uh i know
it's early in the tournament but how
would you say your ambitions are for
this tournament
i can't
say if i'm
playing uh
you know on some mediocre level at least
yes so today's game probably
is full of some other sides so that's
some quite bad news for me but uh
hopefully you know
you know during next rounds i'll like
get in touch with some i don't know
reality and
play better yeah great to have you back
in bucharest and looking forward to see
you in the next games thank you guys
back to you thank you christian thank
you always always colorful let's just
say
yeah yeah self-deprecating interview
there at nepo as he he finds a way of
insulting himself better than i i relate
i relate to that
relating deeply to the position is also
alejandro what's going on in the game
of wesley cell a lot of things got
traded there it's ugly but is it
holdable that's a question that shock
and west you're trying to figure out
here wesley down to 11 minutes against
15 but they're already a move 34 in a
very simplified position i don't expect
time to be a major factor we still have
the same situation two past pawns here
for black completely blockaded by the
dark square
bishop and queen
the thing is without rooks on the board
yes you have this ugly structure on the
king side and this bishop is now great
it's never going to be great but how do
you win where is x where is white going
to win exactly guess you have a pass
pawn on the b file that's great but
obviously it's not going to get past b6
because there is a strong blockade on b7
that this bishop on c5 and c5 can't do
anything about so you could pressure f6
and you could try to combine it with uh
threats of pushing the pawn but is it
going to be enough the computers don't
really like this way for wesley to have
moved forward it's true that you can
torture your opponent forever but you
don't just want to torture him you want
to win as well and it's possible that
the material is just a little bit too
reduced meanwhile in the richard
reporter game we do have a couple of
updates uh after the moving g1 king g7
rook h
sorry about that rook h2 was played and
as expected something came down the h
file the move queen e7 of course was
also possible but
after rook takes h8 it is important to
take with the king uh you cannot take
with the queen because remember the g5
is currently hanging so you have to take
with the king g4 was played which to me
was a little bit of a surprise i
expected to move king g2 and bringing
the other rook to the h uh file instead
after g4 f4 bishop f2 knight d5 levon
has just played the move 94 we have a
still very complex position 10 moves to
go for each player the computers is
giving zeros a wild position so many
different strategical elements to
consider the spawn on g5 being weak do i
really want to trade off this bishop for
the knight but allow f takes e4 that
would remove the knight from d5 but give
me a passport a lot of things to
consider here for both players and i
think that it's just about even
and in bucharest we have christian
carrillo with a guest
thank you alejandro yes uh we are with
ali reza first ali reza first of all
welcome to bucharest this is the first
time here in bucharest what are your
first impressions of the city as well as
the organization yeah i heard a lot of
good things about bucharest
our personal doctor in france is from
romania so
she talks a lot about
workers and i wanted to visit at some
point but
now it's a good time
now for from for now the city is great
we are in the city center so it's pretty
good and
the tournament is also
very well organized except yesterday was
it
in opening ceremony was too long but
okay in general i think
organization is good too one of the
things that i wanted to ask you is uh we
haven't seen you play classical chess in
a while neither online perhaps with some
fake accounts but we haven't seen you
play much what have you been doing for
the past five months or so with you i
just was living my life
they are trying to prepare a little for
candidates
um but in general i was
busy
doing some sports and
and yeah just living the life and
continue preparing for candidates do you
see this tournament as uh your main
preparation for the candidates it's a
great preparation i think just to play
one month before the candidates is a
good schedule also
the players will not get tired
so i think it's a great tournament and
i'm lucky that
everybody's playing in this tournament
all the top players
you started off with a very difficult
game black against fabiano caruana
historically you have quite some
difficulties against him tell us a bit
about your strategy going into this game
and he surprised you at any point in the
opening how do you see this game i think
in general fabiano played i think
two times against me e4 so first move
was a little bit surprised of course
because he's a
very good e4 player that's okay maybe he
wanted
i thought lately he was playing c4 or d4
so
yeah it was also ready for
everything so
i could say the first move was the
biggest surprise in this surprise
and after that you guys uh follow this
interesting new line that it's uh been
developing in real time actually this
move a4 which was also played in a game
between van forest and adams were you
aware of this move
yes this is the top engine moves so
people
see the top engine what they place
but this line i played in s magnus in
norway
not a4 but he played f3 f3 yes i played
b5 and this was the game was draw but it
was very complicated
but uh yes this a4 is a in top engine
move so
i kind of expected this also
so we will continue the little night for
the game yes
he told me fabiano told me after the
game a6 is not very precise but i think
in general these positions the
the structure is very the same like
everywhere the move doesn't matter you
do not lose by force here right
so slow developing game yes
yeah i was not sure about the zero k3 i
think this queen d2 maybe is better to
try to bring the rook on e1
it must be some sort of uh preparation
because we saw actually vampires played
exactly the same thing and quite quickly
this idea with knight wave four in rook
a3 i do believe vampires started with
knight a4 and then following with a3 but
basically the same position this one is
uh where you guys diverged he uh played
the move bishop to e6 adams you play the
move rook to b8 what was your thought
process at this point in the game yes
it's very amazing they played it today
because this line normally they don't
play with black because okay it's a
little bit worse for black and
it's not very popular so to happen in
the same day it's amazing
but yeah in general i think white has a
great destruct bonus structure and
the pieces are out but black is very
solid very solid were you concerned at
any point it seemed like he was also
spending a lot of time were you
surprised by that you were playing quite
fast
was not very familiar with this
structure i think he doesn't have so
many games in cold spot
so
yeah it was he was trying to figure out
how to break through but it's very
difficult here
one last question at the end you guys
repeated the position so many times i
think it was at least four times uh what
was uh the psychological play there
because he was dropping uh down to his
last four minutes you had 30 minutes on
the clock he seemed to hesitate to call
the arbitrary then you had stayed called
the arbiter what was the player so i was
always looking for somehow to continue
the game but it's very difficult i think
for me because he can okay at the
end he has 28 moves 12 moves to go you
can just move the queen go and back
i cannot do anything so
from my point of view i cannot do
anything here so
maybe he could have tried but his four
minutes is
quite difficult with four minutes a very
practical choice by uh fabiano still a
very solid uh game for you with the
black pieces what are your ambitions for
this event i'm trying to
play some good games before the
candidates and
trying to play very solid
and we will see i um
i'm really
i'm
motivated for this tournament so
i
i think it will be a great tournament
all the players are fighting today i saw
many players
are fighting and it's it's great to see
them and reza great to see you back at
the board and we'll see you in the next
few rounds thank you guys back to you
thank you christian very much and uh
peter what what impresses you most
about this uh phenomenal talent
well uh
sort of everything
it's uh
he's just
seems to be
obviously there is still room to grow
right but the the the fact that he is as
well-rounded as a player as he is by by
the age of 18 is the most
is the most impressive sure
he
is not very easily pigeon-holed into
into anything like he obviously is an
incredibly exciting tactical player but
as we've seen today and he said he said
in an interview you've just watched that
you know he was surprised that there
were two high-level games played with
this position
because black is a bit worse and it's
passive exactly uh it's and to me like
that what i wanted to draw attention to
is that he very much understands that he
didn't
exactly equalize and also there is no
counter play right
necessarily at least in the beginning
and this is a kind of a position against
fabi not every 18 year old in the world
will choose
with buffet that's right yeah i can
embrace embrace wholeheartedly this idea
of defending a passive position against
fabi
uh but he seemed very comfortable like
we were talking at some point about him
potentially maybe assuming some of the
initiatives then he maybe misplayed it a
little bit and then
and that went away but but still
yeah
he's
unbelievably good enough already and
there is obviously still still very much
room to grow so
yeah
very exciting to watch him very very
exciting uh
alejandra threw down a gauntlet for us
in the game of wesley so versus shaq
a lot of
pieces got vacuumed off the board what
we do have as a queens and opposite
colored bishop a very grim defense i
used to say for for shaq uh
it's actually really funny because
in my view if i get in the move f3 and
king h2 with nothing happening i just
win
i'm not sure the issue here the issue
here is that
yes it looks fantastic but then let's
say i play i don't know bishop six queen
d7 right and i say
this looks wonderful but um you know if
i if if if we're not talking about me
playing i want to say i'm just not going
to resign then i realize i will probably
actually resign yeah because you're a
very nice person yeah most people would
actually play on but
those those obvious you know opposite
color bishop related jokes jokes right
uh you still have to demonstrate a way
to win this position it really yeah with
happy days we're talking candidates
montpellier 1985 and playing white
against michael tull
i have
this beautiful setup with pawns on g3
g2 and h3 put my king on h2 and i went
very easily
uh against
the
my opponent's forces of queen and bishop
and the point is is that uh
for
black has absolutely no no counter play
and it's interesting that shah actually
went bishop c6 here because this was
maybe the last time in the game where he
could have tried queen e4 queen g3
precisely that's the the one thing i
wanted to avoid which is why i proposed
putting the pawn on the three the king
on h2 if i get that then i get
everything and i can
i've got a free hand while we were
discussing all the other things since
you brought this version up on the
screen i've been sort of thinking about
it and i realized that if you play queen
e4 there yeah we just move it back if
you play queen e4
f3 queen g3 doesn't actually force the
queen's off i have the move queen b2
here in particular right and it
and
f6 is hanging and you have the move
queen b3 and this is another thing that
i wanted to discuss with you i think if
you play queen b3 i take and play b5
this end game might be lost yeah because
these two pawns are actually just simply
wretched despite the fact that this is
currently an equal material opposite
color bishop ending which is really
really which is normally which is
normally not a very difficult thing to
hold yeah exactly yeah b3 is kind of
dead the bishop on b7 is dead extremely
extremely passive right and the bishop
on d4 just controls absolutely
everything so yeah the dangers of this
position cannot really be you know
overstated and right shaq took some time
to decide what to do and chose not to
even engage with any of this playing
with c6
yeah we assume f3 gets played just to
uh make sure that those types of
counterplay never never materialized but
then the question simply becomes oh you
know all of this is good and well but
if black just kind of
greenly goes bishop six queen d7 i don't
know maybe h5 maybe not i don't know
and just passes forever and addresses
the threats as they come you play queen
c5 i play queen d7 right i don't allow
b5 right uh you play queen b6 i'm very
unhappy because i kind of don't have a
good reply to queen b6 but right uh but
generally speaking we just assume this
kind of an extremely
passive posture here as black
and we just because there are so few
pieces it will be difficult for white to
create let's say two threads at the same
time we generally will have to be
dealing with the one thread per move and
maybe there's just enough
resources for black to just to just
parry the one thread that will be
let me get alejandro in on uh this
discussion i mean
we all like wesley's position uh
very very much
how
big an advantage is it it
i mean
here is peter throwing down the gauntlet
it's hard to win
it is hard to win and the more the
engine analyzes the less it likes it for
white i'll start it off at one point
something it keeps thinking goes down to
0.9 then 0.8 and starts realizing that
perhaps what peter is saying is right
that with perfect defense you should be
able to hold this position now perfect
defense is something that's very tough
to achieve when you're playing passively
and responding to threats it's very
common that players crack under such
pressure especially if the time is added
onto it of course seven minutes for
ahmadiyya doesn't really matter because
there are four moves away from time
control so this one i think shaq with
perfect play technically should draw it
but can he achieve perfect play we'll
have to find out it might not be so
difficult if he just has to parry one
thread at a time the one that is getting
into a little bit of trouble in my
opinion is lanier dominguez he is down
to a minute on the clock in this
position perhaps not fully in trouble
but you start seeing that there are
there's a couple of uncomfortable things
here for black the main thing is that
the h file is open and it's a much more
valuable file than the e file because
this rook can't go down to e2 whereas
this rook can definitely go up to h7 and
start harassing the pawns is it again a
position in which white has enough to
break through that is left to be seen
the main thing linear has to make eight
moves in a minute and
a maxim with seven minutes can try to
create some pressure in this position i
think i would start with the move g4 c
where the knight goes perhaps even
consider the move for rook h7 but
unfortunately for white
after the move rook h7 knight d6 you
still have to create
additional threats in the position so
advantage for white in both games both
mvl against linear and wesley against
shock but will it be enough to topple
their opponents that's what we have to
see well knight d6 looks like a really
good
covering the one weakness on f7 uh but
like you say these time merchants you
know it just depends on how well there
is another person who will not at all be
unaccustomed with having a minute for
something and a minute for nine with 30
second increment in a position where you
really
aren't going to be you know solving very
difficult tactical problems it's a
pretty dry position yeah uh i think
linear is
reasonably reasonable
how this is going yeah have you ever
were you ever a time trouble addict or
just the reverse were you i.e you you
no i was i was in constant time travels
when i was a kid
really
horrible time travels as well and then
it just went away without me
really doing anything
consciously about it i just started
playing faster and
uh
it just went away and these days i
actually feel very uncomfortable when
i'm low on time and
i also sort of redefined being low on
time like
you know 10 for 10 these days makes me
nervous
i i remember i played a tournament when
i was about 12. i played in the
quarterfinals of the leningrad
championship which is you know doesn't
sound like much but it was prestigious
yeah leningrad is a is a strong is a
strong city in terms of chess play it
was a good tournament right
and i i won it and i think out of the 11
rounds i played i was in horrible time
trouble in like eight of them
and something like a minute for 20 in
those years was kind of okay for me i
just i i didn't really think it was
anything out of the ordinary and now if
if i find myself with a minute on for 20
i might just kind of just resign and go
home because like i mean it's just
horrible and why should i do that to
myself it's suffering was it was it
totally mechanically
okay that's really uh pressing it uh um
i'm expecting knight d6 uh for lanier i
think that's really a nice little trap
but linear is not playing knight e3
there one would have been a bit of a
mistake but right
i just wanted to really put ourselves uh
on the spot
uh betw for the game of wesley
and shaq
winner
draw i think it ends up being a draw
winner or draw a draw
i'll go with the win okay uh h5 is an
interesting choice there because
i think
trying to discourage the one additional
source of play for white with g2 g4 is
interesting but you now have to solve
the issue of kind of just not dropping
the pawn on h5 i think it starts with
queen e6 because
queen h4 currently is a very strong
threat and if you play king g6 i think
h6 just straight up loses to queen g3
check oops uh so you need to protect the
f6 pawn first to be able to play queen
h4 king g6 and not drop any material
so you think queen e6 is there yeah but
actually now that i look at this queen
h4
queen h4 yeah i was about to
start one specific thing there yes
absolutely king g6 yes and shockingly g2
g4 in this position because there is no
check from e1
no check from so you can trade you can
trade all the pawns and then f5 check is
going to be a very very strong threat
maybe f6 f5 is playable here because
after queen g5 check
king f7
white does win the pawn on the 5 but you
have to relinquish control over the e1
square which is very very relevant
but this is now very concrete and also
i'm wondering if queen takes a five
years winning or not
whoa
are you
willing
i mean willing to better house it
doesn't no no no no no no no not at all
it may be it may even be a simple win
actually as the king can glide straight
away
why are we squares
through c5 i would put so you go bishop
e5 king c3d5 f6 yeah and i go that way
and because the the pawns are so far
um
something concrete in the position
alejandro it's always concrete in chat
especially with computers the line that
you're giving doesn't quite work but
it's for a very weird reason 26 is fine
for black uh the engine's top move is
queen f8 that will definitely not happen
queen e6 though does look pretty logical
and the idea is that even though queen
h4 looks like a very decent move
attacking h5 and hitting f6 and
seemingly forcing king g6 which indeed
gives white a winning advantage after
the move g4 uh there's this kind of
funny move sorry queen f2 queen e6 queen
h4 there's a funny move c3
and suddenly black kind of out of
nowhere has counter play you cannot take
the pawn because check
picks up the bishop
and if you play the move queen h5
then after king g7 you could give me a
check on g5 if you felt like it but
after king f7 you have nothing better
but to repeat moves and this pawn is
actually going down the board we have
another result as levona ronyan and
richard report have found a kind of
unique repetition not really forced into
it but both players unable to find how
to make progress we left the game off
more or less around here with the move
knight e4 some of the rooks got traded
and after b6 bishop d3 bishop e7 the
players repeated this way bishop c4
bishop b4 bishop d3 bishop b7 bishop c4
nothing happened in this position they
are experts at finding threefolds and we
have yet another result and this one
also has spanish to found itself into a
dry
end game uh maxima unable to find much
agrees to a draw another threefold
repetition well we're four for four so
far guys
absolutely i don't i'm not surprised by
the uh
linear repetition i really didn't think
that the rook on h7 was doing anything
but going back and forth
but the very creative and very
confounding game between levon and
richard somehow it got very dry but by
the final position
yeah but once all the rooks disappeared
along the age file i think uh
yes as alejandro said it's a kind of an
artificial looking repetition which i
think players these days are very expert
at finding those
especially where no draw offers are
allowed but if you look at this position
nobody really is going anywhere 93 check
is never going to be a threat bishop
takes e4 conversely also it's just not a
very good move so you're never really
intending to do that
so it's very difficult to make any kind
of progress for uh for anybody here and
it's understandable that they chose to
uh i mean they would have agreed to draw
here but since that is not an option
people kind of there is a kind of
you know wink-wink nudge-nudge situation
happening and exactly and that's making
progress are you making progress no
we're
going back and forth uh
and uh yeah only one game one and i was
as soon as alejandro said queen f8 is
never happening i thought yeah
commentator's curse you did never never
say it's never happening queen f8 in
fact did happen um
it's strange
if i just go back here to this position
uh the move i'm playing all the time i
want king h2 end of story i i definitely
don't i think the reason for queen of
two is that i think with white you get
the feeling here that
black is about to establish some kind of
a perimeter which will be hard to breach
and by playing queen f2 we're trying to
attack some weaknesses before that
perimeter is established
but i don't understand what the
fortress that you're going to establish
this whereas
for for example if i go king h2 yeah i
stop these c3 tricks and i get to go
queen a7
and i don't have to worry about uh the
c3 uh but let's say
if black gets enough time to play as
we've discovered as we've described like
queen e6 king g6 um it's going to be
quite difficult to break this down and
i mean you can start from the other side
you can go like queen a to hero queen b2
and start creating threats on that side
sure but all those things also allow
queen d6 which might be a bit awkward
because if four pawn is
we don't really want to play g3 and we
don't really want to allow queen takes
f4 so
i think f2 is very understandable
decision because he he wants to
ask questions before move forward as
well i think that's also
a part of the equation here is that
white really
no like wesley knows he's like he can
probably pass for three moves and still
not be at least okay
so
like you could go bishop c3 queen d4
and d2 but yeah but shakira is somewhat
low on time so i think it makes
practical sense for for wesley to try
and find questions to ask before shakira
gets his half an hour and more 40. all
right so i think mf2 is logical i just
queen f2 queen f8 okay so let's say uh
one of these days i'm not actually going
to be able to
uh get the setup i want which is
actually funnily enough to put my king
on h4
which i do believe uh
it's kind of untouchable yeah so i'll
put my queen on d4 which
kind of forces you ties ties black down
to uh f6 and then i i believe that b for
b5 uh i'm going to be able to press that
one absolutely yeah it's a
i like bishop but first uh let's uh
jump over to bucharest as we have a
christian uh with lanier dominguez
christian
thank you yasser yes we are here with
lanier dominguez another first timer
here in bucharest first of all linear
welcome to my hometown bucharest what is
uh your first impression about the city
as well as
the organization yeah it's great i mean
the city seems uh very nice i was doing
uh i was walking around a little bit
and
it seems very nice that people
are very friendly and uh looking forward
to to have some more time to explore
maybe on the rest day
and yeah the organization so far is
great i mean we have
amazing conditions and
i feel really
that everything is ideal to just play
play chess you came from st louis
directly from a very taxing event the
american cup uh how do you feel right
now in terms of energy also there's some
jet lag potentially how do you feel in
terms of it i feel quite okay in general
i mean i had a few days
after the american cup i had like a week
it's one of the pluses of
not reaching the finals
and uh and i feel i feel good i of
course it's a bit difficult with the jet
lag it's uh eight hours different so
it gets uh
difficult uh even more and more
difficult with time i guess to to get
over this but i i think i'll be fine in
terms of uh chess it definitely feels
like you found a new weapon with the
black pieces the petrov defense it's uh
really playing quite well for you take
us through this game and the critical
moments did you feel at any point that
your opponent was finding any sort of
unpleasant pressure
i think it was of course it wasn't much
uh the line is very solid even um even
if white gets the
pair of bishops like like it was the
case
so after
uh yeah uh after bishop f3 in the
opening i wasn't sure if i should play
knight seven it's a little bit passive
move because i also had uh bishop b6
seems a bit more
uh
logical and then if white takes on e6 at
some point for example then black i
think will be able to play long castle
bishop d6 e5 in some some form and it
looks okay but peter also said that this
move is almost an automatic and then
alejandra hold him no no actually the
engine wants knight e7
did you feel uncomfortable blocking the
bishop or anything of that nature or did
you feel like you have enough time to
get out yeah i thought that uh
uh just intuitively i didn't want to
give the bishop so fast so soon and i i
thought that my position is solid enough
to to be able to play 97
uh without consequences and it's
probably right because
again it's very solid castle short
and
i thought bishop f5 is natural
and uh rookie won
long castle uh all very logical 92 yeah
96 knight f1 here there were many lines
to calculate for example uh yeah the
problem is that white uh wants to play
knight knight e3 or knight g3 so that's
why i decided to sacrifice a pawn with
bishop d6 but i think if white takes on
d5 i have this knight h4
and i was pretty happy with this
position knight of six knight f3 df df
and i'm
pawn down but rook g8 h5 is coming
bishop h3 the king on g1 it's black has
the two bishops and i think it's
probably enough compensation here and it
does feel like the engine does agree
with you it feels like this rook g8 h4
is really coming quickly yeah so he
decided to go uh knight gta knight g3 uh
rook e8 i thought this natural and uh
yeah we should be free
at h4
and bishop d2 initially i thought that
uh i'm able to play 94 in this position
but then i i wasn't sure about bishop d4
and i have to play g6 and i didn't like
it so much
so
i thought i should play something like
c6 and then we get this position where
white uh indeed keeps the two bishops
and some hope of let's say using the
bishops later but i think black's
position is anyway like very very solid
so i was just trying to
uh not to
to
to play i mean to create weaknesses or
something but i think if black plays
normal then it should be fine when did
you feel like uh you are fully equalized
at which point were you sure certain
about uh your chances i mean i saw
i think after bishop g3 i was uh
relieved because uh at least i'm um
i'm
taking one of the bishops and and i saw
this plan with h5 and so on where i get
to simplify and bring my net to d6 later
which looks extremely solid i was
thinking in the
almost at the end
uh when i played knight five in this
position uh i i was thinking about the
move for four because i thought that the
only chance for white is somehow to
get a 495 on rook h7
in some way
and uh for example 96 95 and if
something like that of six let's say
trying to prevent rook h7 then maybe
king f3 in this position play try to
play g4 d5 i felt that maybe this is a
little bit of pressure still for white
but uh yeah i wasn't sure what what's
the best way after f4 so i was kind of
happy when when he went g4 because then
i think it's very difficult after 96
it's very difficult now for white to to
to create the threat of 95 because i
always have 94 check after f4 so i don't
see
um what y can do here so it's probably
full equalizing at this point in general
uh players need one or two rounds to
feel like they're back in shape do you
feel like after this game you're back in
playing shape yeah definitely i think
also the american cup was hopeful in
that sense so i
felt pretty pretty good like from from
today so i i think i will have no issues
on on that in that sense perfect thank
you very much
and we're looking forward to seeing the
next few rounds thank you guys thank you
christian and thank you lanier um
any uh progress being made by wesley uh
well he progressed progressed all the
way to move 40 so he can now pause and
and think about potential he gets his
extra half hour here again i mean i've
been
beating uh
the table
pretty hard that i want to play
uh bishop to see through the board queen
to d4
bring my king to h5 and then pardon me
bring my king to h4 not that i'm really
ready to take the pawn maybe i even want
to just play g3 and just like just stay
just entomb it there yeah
and get mated by king g6 queen g5
precisely
that's that that that that's the intent
but
now that they've reached time control
we're just going to take a a break
oops
i apologize
i apologize we will be going to
christian not quite away
and here we have the language of chess
fancy play syndrome all the way at the
top how did that i mean it's funny they
found they found four actual
things of chess and then they added two
that i've never heard of before
no lpgo exists yeah that that's like
some
that's really just scholastic
i learned a lot in this broadcast i have
to say that
swish and zoo zeit not now those i was
really really really proud of as a kid
that i but i actually had a lot of
tactical
stuff that i i patted myself on the the
smothered maids you know the fact that i
knew what the smothered name was really
you know i
elevated me to like class d
i'm sorry
thank you
and there we go okay
and we go to bucharest more interviews
yeah more interviews with a christian
thank you guys uh yes we are here with a
richie rapport a new full-time player on
the grand chess tour first of all richie
welcome back to bucharest tell us a bit
about how does it feel to be a full-time
granchester player actually i was
supposed to be a full-time player also
the last season right but i but there
were some problems yeah i i fell ill in
last minute just before coming to
bucharest and then i had to skip this
event and then
i kind of had a you know disadvantage
compared to the other side missing one
crucial event so now i'm very happy that
to have to have made this one and
actually you know aside from this one
day which i spent in bucharest
last year i haven't really been here so
i really i'm enjoying the city so far
what are your first impressions of uh
the playing hall as well as the
organization of the tournament so far
applying hope is fine i mean uh hotel is
of course very nice the playing field is
fine
organization is always great right you
know so
i'm not i can't complain too much yeah
um my play is you know could be better
could be worse but everything else is
nice i like the area where we are
actually staying so i i like to you know
stay in such areas in this uh more
crowded areas so like i feel you know at
home
well speaking of chess and your play
your play was definitely quite exquisite
take us through the game it certainly
felt like after this move f5 how did you
feel at this point it almost felt like
you're taking over the initiative oh
yeah i felt uh pretty confident about my
my position my chances overall right
because i went for this love which i
haven't played um for a while but okay
lavon reacted uh
as he does usually pretty quickly and
confidently but then you know okay when
you look at the position
and that's the opponent here sometimes
you realize okay he might be confident
that there might be some
some blocking some some holes here some
bluffing going on so i felt like after a
fire i was doing really well but then um
he went for this extremely strange plan
with
h4 and i don't know king dj truck c1
and uh yeah i couldn't really see at
this point like um what was of course
engine is giving big advantage and i
also feel like okay i don't think you
know black could be worse here ever
black is clearly the one who is pulling
the shots sort of but i just couldn't
figure and then i went for 97 which
was such a good practical move i think
because after 97 um
yeah i kind of forced him to do
something with the c 4 pawn right and
he played e5 but even if he would have
gone for ef5 i don't have a
such a big advantage so i guess i should
have been kind of braver or something
and just
make another waiting move here and
see what he was because the problem was
that if i would have done captured a
pawn maybe fifa is more precise so let's
take it like this start with uh yeah
bishop c3
just b takes and the bishop takes uh b4
and here he'll play e4 later on so frank
and queen uh takes the bishop
and
the c43 and the michael inside is and
you're following that he has enough and
he has a square and then and all right
so i can't really do this
but yeah here um
here probably like you know bishop h5 or
something or h6a just to just to wait
out because you know if you play e5 now
i have a knight on v6 which
basically gives me like two extra tempi
and it's seven knight to b6 yeah yeah
yeah with that i have done to
force a pro e5 but afterwards i was
still fine here at this point but
probably not nothing nothing more i had
a feeling it was natural from this point
on to
to end up
making a draw here and uh
anastasia was telling us quite an
interesting uh fact you will be playing
quite a lot of chess leading up to
probably one of the most important
tournaments of your life the candidates
you will also be playing in norway uh
what is your strategy how do you
approach the candidates well i whatever
strategy i would have wished to make
was kind of ruined by my
basically speaking by my lack of
confidence i guess to qualify right
because i figured i'm never going to
qualify to the candidates uh you know i
i haven't even tried since i think 2017
was my my last event in a circuit before
this gp
and then yeah so i asked for the gp to
you know um have the possibility to to
because i played vacancy and i had to
play just right after have the
possibility to skip skip one of the
first two gps uh okay i didn't work out
with fidel they scheduled me to play
them and then i figured i have
absolutely no chances to qualify because
of the busy schedule uh and or and as
you know i figured okay why not to play
events that i'm invited to right and
then uh yeah i
somehow you know qualifying right now so
they forced me and then and then i and
then i got stuck here and then i got
stuck with these events which i can't
really uh i guess it wouldn't be even
too fair but also it's i can't really
back back out of them so yeah at the end
of the day my preparation will be just
you know
play
everything i play more chess than i have
played in years in this two months and
then hope that you know at the moment i
go to get to the candidates i'm not a
full-time zombie yet so i can still uh
you know calculate two moves straight
yeah it's not it's far from ideal but
this is what it is
speaking of uh that uh specifically for
the candidates we know that preparation
and having a lot of uh well analyzed
ideas let's say is uh quite important do
you feel in any way exposed uh by
playing so much yeah absolutely i mean i
even try to get some support from uh
from my country from hungary or from
federation or something of course this
completely backfired like it always does
with them i asked for some you know
basically some support from anyone
didn't really work so i figured okay i i
will just take candidates as one of the
many tournaments because okay what can
you do yes i love you so it's life so at
the end of the day uh if you are not
having the right cards i mean obviously
you can't hope for too much so yeah
we'll just play every separation all
these events spoiler alert that's what i
am going to do so and then we will see
um
hopefully i mean i still hope that i
can get lucky enough to post some
threats to these guys but of course
they'll they will be all arrested and
prepared so i my oats are you know
kind of slim i believe
i'm pretty sure you will definitely pose
a lot of problems to all your
competitors in the candace thank you
very much richie for joining us and
we'll see you in the next few rounds
thanks guys back to you
i could never qualify i would never
qualify so i accepted all that
that was quite an interview yeah
once again i felt like i
you could identify a little bit because
i could and in this particular case it's
not even the the self-deprecation and
the kind of the i could never qualify
and i don't have i don't stand a chance
in the candidates even though that part
i also probably have said over the years
right on occasion it's the
this idea that people ask you things and
you just answer right it's uh he's just
not
doesn't have a particularly promising
political career
he's not edgy
mastering mustering the art of hearing
the question and then saying something
that you want to say which is
particularly
you know in some cases just unrelated to
the question
you know he he he got asked some things
he just straight up told us what he
thinks right which is very refreshing
and he's a wonderful wonderful guy i've
spent some time last year with him i
really really like him
but
this this sort of extreme honesty is uh
i asked my federation and as usual i got
nothing in return and it kind of
rebounded against me yeah
so
it's very refreshing to see to see
people just sort of answer questions
fully and honestly
and everything but
sometimes you do feel that maybe it's
not the best policy
[Laughter]
wonderful and as we take a break we have
one game remaining in this opening round
of our grand chess tour we'll see on the
other side of the break
[Music]
it's time for the return of the grand
chest tour featuring the world's best
players in some of the most unique
places across the globe romania poland
croatia and the united states join us in
may as we kick off the 2022 tour in
romania and then immediately followed by
poland this is your chance to see the
best players in the world's greatest
game follow all of the action live at
granchester.org
chess the smartest game on earth
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello and welcome back to our coverage
of the first
leg of the grand chester 2022 we only
have one game running in in bucharest as
you can see from
from the view of the playing hall it is
wesley with the white pieces pressing
against uh shakira mandarif
and we'll get to that in a moment for
now we can just
watch them deeply
deeply in thought
shah is not enjoying this very much you
can even see it sort of from from this
camera angle he
the
the lack of enjoyment yeah he's not a
happy camper as unfortunately for him he
he is suffering
this opposite color
middle game
barney end game position of queen
bishop versus queen and bishop and
the problem that he's facing is
this the complete lack of counter play
i've i've been harping for some time to
get the king to h4 to get this set up
with the queen and the bishop and
get the pawn to b6 he's going back to d2
that is what that is a confusing choice
to me i don't quite know why we would
vacate the best square on the on the
chessboard right maybe he wants to
i have no idea how to explain this
in in the break we
apart from actually taking a break i've
also
had a look at what the machine was
saying and the machine is actually very
much in favor of completely dooming the
king on h4 by playing g2 g3 because i
was somewhat in jest i was saying that
if you play g3 you probably get mated
because the queen from d6 can get to g5
uh but it actually can't not because
there is no path but because the pawn f6
will be hanging in the process so you
the amount of moves you need to get
through the queen from the sixth g5 by
the time you're threatening the goku
queen g5
queen takes f6 check yeah and uh foil
your plan
if we
if he had continued g2 g3 then the idea
of making further progress bishop
queen
bishop queen and b5 kind of starts to
play itself yeah and
the point about playing g3 is that if
the idea of playing the queen to g5
never really materializes black really
is completely and utterly stalemated and
well not stalemated but doesn't have
anything to look forward to and
eventually the white queen will start
making progress because black will not
be able to defend every single way
uh into their castle uh there so you you
start getting dragged in different
directions and eventually something
falls but wesley seemingly uh played 22
with the intention of putting the bishop
on the fourth which i don't i don't mind
it's just that
activating the queen from d2 will
perhaps be a bit slower than doing it
from d4 obviously because you still need
to find squares for it
um
also my queen is actually tied to this
pawn he will have to play he'll have to
play g3 at some point right
uh
jump right in alejandro your take on
this
changing of the guard of wesley putting
his bishop on d4 instead of leaving the
queen there there's one good thing about
shaq's position is that he has no plans
so all he has to do is bishop c6 and d7
until wesley actually presents a threat
so yeah he's rearranging his pieces the
computer still wants to go g3 anyway and
say that well you can step side step
queen b2 queen a2 you can always
penetrate down the a5 a little bit later
you never want to give up the f6 pawn
you'll probably end up checkmated
somehow so b4 is not so easy to capture
uh that being said there hasn't been a
lot of progress being made recently by
wesley
he still has 16 minutes which is plenty
considering that he has a an increment
but at some point he's going to have to
buy the bullet he's going to have to
eventually either decide if he wants to
play the move g3 or if he wants to put
the queen somewhere on the a file um
threaten something because he is running
out of useful ideas at the moment he
will be forced at some point to show
some kind of card
in order to make progress he'll have to
show his hand and the
something you said there about not
necessarily even needing to protect the
pawn on before like if i play g3 here
in some positions i can imagine even
queen a2 queen takes before in queen a8
being enough of a threat
uh to not even have to waste the tempo
on queen between queen a3
maybe not for the bishop on c6 because
it covers the a8 square but so let me
put the bishop on e8 so yeah and then
yeah something yeah like queen a2 uh
queen before uh queen although allowing
queen seven here is not that great the
line that was attracting me was queen
eight bishop f7 uh no if we continue
there
before i attacked the bishop
and i kind of counted bishop f7 here as
forest and then after queen g8 we just
win because the queen on before is so
dominated
that the opponent of six actually falls
here which is quite quite pretty wow but
the issue is black of course will not
play bishop f7 they will play uh queen
e7
okay queen takes d5 and now bishop f7
and this position while still very
pleasant for white is not going to be
enough yeah the trade of the b-pawn for
the d-pawn is actually great for black i
mean that's a terrible terrible uh pawn
and you've traded off the pad which
again i mean the queen was doing so
nicely on d4 just a few moves ago if we
had put our pawn on g3 exactly and
uh
jumping
into this very nice square a7
i understand him wanting to put the
bishop on d4 because allowing d5d4 is
one way that something goes wrong here
right but yeah i thought we could do it
in a more active fashion without
retreating with the queen obviously we
would have preferred to have the queen
on a more active square
i guess i guess he's sort of reluctant
to play g3 because g3 is
a kind of a move that you can't really
take back g3 says i am very convinced
nothing but is ever going to happen to
that king
uh
and i am going to win sort of with this
setup i realized because you probably
don't really want to play g4 unless it
actually just wins on the spot right so
that's a very committal choice because
with the pawn steel on g2 he could at
some point you know reconsider and just
go king i don't know king
g3 yeah
g3 does sort of lock you into one
winning plan and uh rules out
some of the others but it has to be done
he has now done it
finally
by the way i just refreshed my board g2
g3
with the queen on d2 and not the queen
on d4 one of the things peter that i
think um
well just the the quality of the players
include their their chess
but
it seems to me whether it's because of
table bases or because of chess engines
just the
technique
of the players is just outstanding i
mean all of these guys are great and
game players
yeah i think uh
it's it's slightly weird right because
you would have assumed
that the quality of like like and i
think it might even be true that
the quote-unquote general endgame
knowledge may have gone somewhat down
uh comparing comparing the let's say
this generation of players to
the i don't know two three generations
ago because
no adjournments
made it so that
uh you didn't really need to study
perhaps as deeply some of the positions
that you know you absolutely need it
uh but on the other hand
even if that is true it doesn't seem to
be reflected very much in what we're
watching because a lot of people are
like the current crop of players are all
very very strong engine players exactly
uh and uh i think it comes back to the
fact that
well
end games
when all is said and done are
a lot of good end game play is just
clean calculation
indeed uh and these guys are just so
good
at calculating that
they can very
nicely get by without you know having
read the
the classification the classics and you
know studied all of the the necessary
end games that you are supposed to study
simply because they can
that is not to say that they don't no i
think
uh
magnus clearly knows and i'm pretty sure
that many of the other top top players
actually do have a very sound
understanding of
of the
uh the quote unquote basic endgame so
you know right the question is where
you're going to lie yeah yeah
at what point end games stop stop being
basic and become and become you know
things to
things to work out but uh it's
uh it's possible to work things out over
the board and these guys are incredibly
strong at that just to remind everybody
in our first round of play we have had
four
count em four draws four out of five
with one game remaining wesley so our
grand chess tour
champion uh
is enjoying an advantage against shaq
um
the game between fabi and farruja
i don't want to say fizzled uh so much
as um
it seemed
like both players were content
it was it wasn't an interesting game but
i mean
it was a day that promised more let's
actually let's just be honest with that
it was again we started with a couple of
games that we were looking forward to
favi against alireza yeah and we got
some position which alireza decided to
take a passive position let's see what
favi can come up with we had another
cool game in the levon against richard
so much craziness f5 breaks and then
fizzled it just completely fizzled out
we're left with this opposite color
bishop in which one side is torturing
the other but the result is still quite
unclear it was not the exciting round
that it painted itself to be at some
point exactly when we came in the studio
we were so excited uh by this clash of
generations if i can say that fabi's
still young
yeah there's a 13-year gap between them
yeah but not only that even even if you
just you know talk about the position
we've had after the first hour i think
jan had a very very promising position
again
and uh
the five game did feature some swings
but it was the structure was always so
so solid and so immovable that that's
not really the one but in particular i
think the young uh the the young game uh
versus bogdan and the
uh
the game that we talked quite a bit
about the live on uh versus ritchie yeah
those two uh could have gone could have
gone very very differently but uh
some inaccuracies in in the unscathed
and let's just take a look at the
upcoming stops on the grand chester uh
as you can see on your screen there is
basically back-to-back back-to-back
events so the one that you're watching
right now will be almost immediately
followed by the super bet rapid and
blitz uh in our
players getting on the train yeah
transporting
going to warsaw and playing uh playing
in that and then there will be a bit of
a break because obviously the candidates
yeah the candidates goes uh goes in
between uh but in july there will be a
rapid blitz in zagreb in which magnus
carlsen joins the uh the grand chess
tour for this one and then as usual
uh the tour uh culminates in two events
uh in saint louis in august
uh starting with the rapid and blitz and
then
oh
and then and then of course the sinkhole
cup uh running into september to finish
it out and this is the big news of
course is that come next year
uh the grand chess tour
the two top finishers will qualify
to the candidates tournament that we'll
be watching in a month's time so it's
very nice to see this cooperation
between the fide council and the grand
chess tour
absolutely those two logos have not
really been seen together very much
until now until this announcement and so
it's it's a good cooperation it's too
absolutely and with you 100 too i think
that
it goes both ways and that while we do
have this wonderful group
of um
i want to say tour participants you once
you start to say hey you can qualify as
a candidate you kind of want to open up
the pool a little bit more to wild cards
and more events as well absolutely yeah
it remains to be seen exactly what what
it will do to the composition of the
tour into the composition of the
tournaments in the tour like whether it
will increase the number of participants
where whether it will increase the
number of wild cards
they have they have definitely already
said i think it was outright stated that
uh there will have to be more classical
events because uh you know the the cycle
itself is
classical classical chess so uh for
granted currently is two classical
events and three rapids and perhaps this
uh this has to be shaken up a little bit
uh but
um
one thing for me for sure and i loved it
was when
the grand chess tour
included norway chess that was a that
was and still is one of the really great
uh classical tournaments on tour and to
have that
come back into the grand chess tour
might be that would be that would be
quite good
once again it's very difficult to sort
of preempt and and guess what exactly
will happen but
i will say that
having having branches to cooperate
closely with fiji is something that
bodes well yeah bodes well for the
future of both
yeah jump
over to you alejandro as you're keeping
an eye on this game uh i'd like this
idea of wesley's to sneak the queen out
to a3 well the question is yeah exactly
queen a4 how do we refute queen a4 uh
well the engines are saying that finally
there is a breakthrough for uh for white
the evaluation has jumped from seven
point eight to plus two two point
something so it does think that white
has a good at least attempt to break
through and it starts with the move
queen e3 i know that the moves here are
a little bit on the dodgy side but it
becomes a little bit concrete the point
is that right now in this precise second
you cannot play the desirable move queen
d7 notice that queen e6 27 penetrations
are very dangerous here specifically
queen e6 threatening queen g8 threatens
the pawn on f6 so you want to play the
move queen d7 but queen
no now because this queen e6 is such a
strong move we go back to the point that
if this pawn on the b file is captured
by the queen at the wrong time you will
simply be faced with queen e6 and that's
actually made in six that's actually
surprising to me but it's made in six so
you can't touch the pawn if you play b5
and allow me to play b6 we're just going
to get into the similar end games but
completely lost for black because in so
many variations i can simply sacrifice
uh my piece for a queen
uh a queen trade and the pawn will be
unstoppable i i have a feeling i might
know what charger may have missed
because uh i i saw this entire sequence
but i thought this is still sort of
playable for black v5 queen takes b5 and
by the way everything up the queen d7 is
on the board so wesley now has the
option after community six i thought
queen c6 and why is this so horrible
until you see queen g8 queen g8 king h6
and then g4
this is what i missed
g4 and there is
or g5 mate yeah yeah and that would be
it that yeah there's no way to defend
here yeah i thought the idea here is to
play queen h8 check in that position
instead of g4 i thought okay what what
do we have here check take on f take on
h5 take on f5 might still be winning but
didn't really seem to me like it's
completely unplayable for black
interesting and it's not winning at all
actually yeah yeah so
and then and then and once you mentioned
the words mate in six i thought yeah i'm
probably missing something that maybe
six is slightly more powerful and
i don't think wesley i don't think
wesley's missing it actually
already played by wesley but this is
just gonna collapse yeah that's this is
this is over it's the same again we've
had for a while but the pawn made it all
the way to b6 i saw a moment if you
could put the queen back on a4 and i
thought it was far more testing than
this was king f7 yeah the thing about
king f7 and you don't want to do it
immediately but you have it at some
point is you can actually take on h5
like there will be a moment where you
take on h5 go back with the king go g4
exactly and well thank you for your h
pawn now i have a pass to h pawn myself
i'll hide the king eventually i'm
actually not sure if this is losing or
anything i'm i'm sorry i'm dropping the
b4 pawn there's no reason to give black
that i can play them with queen c3
defend this one attack this one and then
take on h5 next move and the engine say
yeah why not take the pawn it's a free
one that's an important one as well it's
not like the f pawn it's an h one that
creates another passer so this is also
winning for the white side and we have
the move queen takes b5 a hundred
percent mamadiarov missed the move g4
because you don't allow mate in six
otherwise but matey's six is on the
board i don't think wesley's missing it
queen e6 is coming we can probably just
switch to the cameras as
i think has realized i think there's
something wrong something foul is in
this position
and i think yeah
uh
yeah we all we all predicted all right
like no
i know you took the win yeah you did
this no no no no you took the win yeah
yeah prediction master over there i was
hoping that you were going to bring a
little balance into the universe and
you know i've been on this horrifying
streak of just
maybe that's how the world works and you
know who am i to you know
just balance just balance the scales i
mean
but made in sex yeah and i i think that
that that uh picture we had of shaq this
one really says a thousand words
he's just he's just thinking i i i i
don't want to say that uh
he just resigned he just resolved
he stopped
the clock he didn't even wait for
queenie says he didn't even wait for
wesley to go back i i don't want to say
that this is
not a particularly flattering angle
yeah wesley
away from the board hasn't realized that
she resigned but i mean
the moment you see
the queen
dropping on g8
and
then you see wesley sprinting back
accepting that he's won the game and
that's our first decisive result of
bucharest in a little bit of a shocking
fashion to me right yeah it kind of
ended suddenly yeah
no we really expected the long squeeze
if that
was going to be the win
but i must say um
shaq really didn't make things a little
bit too easy for his opponent i mean
once we get here
but maybe maybe this is just bad maybe
you
like it's bad but you can still try of
course yeah i mean you don't have to
lose this in three moves but right uh
perhaps he just did not believe this was
sort of uh holdable slowly and he he
felt that
yeah perhaps this was one of his last
tries right after the move g3 he still
has the move bishop b5 keeping this
queen
on uh
out of your position for the time being
yeah you because he will have queen a6
because you'll have queen a6 against
most things
and
just uh
queen a6 and if i try to go back we can
go back to d6 so i guess this is this is
the stance yeah we
you you've got
you're covering this business square and
everybody's happy h5 is pretty happy as
well happy was very strong
i agreed agreed agreed though
i was i was taking liberty so bishop b5
uh
was it alejandro that was his last and
best chance i don't know if he was his
last chance and honestly i don't know if
mathematically white could break through
anyway but it would at least force
wesley to find it whereas i think
once you played queen a4 queen e3 and
allowed b5 i understand he missed g4 i
guess at the end of that variation but
this just collapses very quickly
again this is where uh
pardon me this is where
the game is shaq stopped the clock
not waiting for queen e6 which would
have won
as follows
the mate
as you said peter
gave
gave the ball away i mean it's g4 and
frankly g5 is mate g5 just happens yeah
yeah and it's just over
and uh shaq realizing that didn't even
wait for
for uh wesley to find it
so we do have a clear winner as wesley
so our grandchild store champion uh yeah
off to a good start leading
lapping the field after lapping the
field um this is wesley's comfort zone
he gets a win early and then just plays
very very very solidly the rest of the
tournament i've seen him win tournaments
where he goes a couple of points early
in the event that just stops playing
chess basically he's kind of hard to
stop when he when he tries to play
defensively i want to see if he tries to
go all out for the tournament or if he's
going to be satisfied with an early plus
one
exactly
for shaq
terrible start yeah not great yeah yeah
not great and uh he obviously uh you
know not the start he wanted not just
because he lost but also like the the
way the game went the the yeah from the
portuguese bishop f4
it's just sort of like he never really
got out of the gate with any kind of a
decent position i mean from more or less
i want to say basically this point
onwards he was playing on the back foot
as alejandro explained at the time this
position actually is
surprisingly fine for black if you play
extremely precisely and you can probably
uh trace it back to this idea to spend
210p on a a5 and 8x before because
the engines do equalize somehow instead
of a5 queen c7 was the move that
alejandro was mentioning is as the way
to go here intending to play knight f8
and then bishop ca trade the bishop f5
away
not easy none of this none of this is
very intuitive because it feels like
it's it's going to be too slow but
engines are good engines are good what
can we say
let's uh jump to bucharest as christian
is with our winner wesley so christian
thank you yasser yes i am with a very
happy uh wesley so wesley first of all
welcome uh back to bucharest you had a
difficult time at the american cup but
now you're
back with a vengeance with a great
victory tell us a bit about that but
also it seems like the grand chester is
somehow your favorite event you play so
well in this event well it's just a
first game today but i'm very happy to
have won to granchester so far uh so
uh
today it's an honor to play shakur mom
in europe who is one of the strongest
players ever and i'm just very glad to
to be here to be invited because we have
all the best players in the world
basically and uh yeah after the
tournament in st louis where it seems
like i could win a game like i was
feeling so bad like i feel like i'm one
of the worst players in the world
so this is uh this is definitely
a big start i i mean i'm very glad to to
have won a game against chatrier of
course i'd like to thank my mother
who's very supportive to me through good
times and bad
and also people from saint louis who
never seem to lose hope for me even
though i lose hope myself and also
especially i'd like to thank tony rich
for wishing me luck today and i always
seem to play well every time he wishes
me
did you have any uh problems adjusting
to the time zone coming from the united
states and when did you get here yeah i
that's one good point i actually came
here two days before the arrival date so
i arrived here may 1st
i believe uh so i had some time also my
mom and i take no jet lag pills and i
was very disciplined this time i slept
on the plane and i did some training
before the tournament obviously i can
only do so much and at the same time i
wanna play more focused here than
than before but i think if you arrive
four days before the first game you
should be fine but everyone's getting
older that's uh that's actually a great
insight for us to know and for all the
professional players to know how to
approach these type of situations now
let's get into the game you repeated
this uh interesting line with e3 you uh
had a nice discussion with sam savion
yeah
the american cup and now you repeated it
again i'm sure you improved on that game
yeah but did he surprise you with this
move a6 at all actually i'll tell you
why i repeated this line so
obviously i analyzed it but also
my game against sam sebian was not in
the latest database yet
so
i mean i'm sure so you don't think he
saw it no i don't think he saw my game
against him
i mean i'm sure he heard of the
american cup like shaq but i uh
he i don't think he's seen my game
against time because he's not the latest
mega database update i will definitely
have to ask him about that we will get
him on the show i'm 100 sure because he
started thinking here like here i
usually like i played a3 many times
before
and so like here he started thinking
already
and actually
he went for the quiet line a6 like sam
played c6 here and the position just
exploded into very complicated but
basics is more quiet because now i can
decide to go short castle yeah
no more of that
queen more wide stuff
yeah and uh so i prepared here
knight f4 94 was your preparation still
yeah i think uh it was
my memory tell me correctly this was
recharge report against we did in the
berlin in or in the serbia grand prix i
think we did play bishop b7 if i
remember
b1 and then a4 ideas
so i was very surprised when he took but
yeah i i think white is
better here but
it felt like you maintained your
advantage all throughout the game and
yeah i was hoping but but yeah maybe
somehow at some point this move f6 came
on the board and it did felt uh i feel
like you have a lot of control in the
position
at any point did you feel like he's
getting back into the game at all yeah i
mean there were many interesting points
in the game like here okay knight a4
also here
yeah maybe knight a4 wasn't the best but
i mean i could play bc5 and just get a
slightly better position but of course
it's far from a win
and uh yeah here i was thinking bishop
f1 bishop f5 but i guess black is
bishop f1 instead of bishop five with a
different idea to move that bishop on
the long diagonal or yeah just to keep
the bishop there and put pressure on the
c45 i could bring my bishop on d4 yeah
but i just basically basically just want
to keep the bishop there if i have time
to consult it
but uh yeah here wasn't sure i feel like
also shaq didn't definitely didn't play
his best chess today but for that i'm
very happy
you should be grateful for that of
course yeah definitely because i thought
he could play knight e4 on move 23.
um maybe the computer doesn't like it
also here i was expecting queen h4 of
course yeah black has to play change for
here to try to create counter play
i mean f6 was too passive like basically
just playing four draw
and
yeah i don't know i mean i i of course
white is better but
with the opposite color bishop you never
know if you're going to convert or not
so better not expect anything special
especially with a lot of well limited
material after uh the exchange of the
rooks as well as the knights
now
when did you feel like you took over at
least psychologically you you came up
with this plan this king to h4
how did you come up with that idea
well i was getting very low on time here
so i had
less than a minute left after i played
queen beethoven move 38 so i was just
moving around but actually shaq told me
after the game that he regretted
allowing the doubled f pawns so he could
have played maybe
uh
he said maybe knight takes shacks with
knight takes d4 and then e8
i mean probably black holds the draw
i think he was regretting the fact that
he allowed this double punch his double
pawn the engine doesn't seem to mind it
one bit uh so
yeah here i saw this idea but
it's probably not winning with against
perfectly
of course it's
it's not easy to defend it in practical
terms
and uh
yeah maybe i have a better point after
queen to b2 queen to c6
came as a
shock to you at all or
what was the big shocking moment
well when he took on b5am because that
just came over
uh and he just resigned he didn't even
wait for you to make your move yeah if i
were you surprised by that i think he
just forgot that i have g4 here
i mean probably bishop's sister also
wins yeah bishop
but he forgot
but it's so funny like here i mean
i wasn't sure i was going to win because
my king is stuck on h4 but i think shaq
has kind of
lost optimism at this point in the game
like he didn't like his pawn structure
he didn't like this position uh
he's his bishop is very passive very
it's dead for the whole game so i think
he lost
some hope at this point a big victory
for you with the white pieces against
the winner of last year's super bad
chess classic what are your ambitions
for this event
well play well and try to
try to do better than
how i did in st louis
for the most part but i'm very glad to
win today also because the game was very
long and
unfortunately it was a decisive game
wesley thank you very much and we're
looking forward to seeing the rest of
your games thank you
guys back to you thank you christian
congratulations wesley let's just take a
quick look at the standings as we have
one decisive win and that's wesley so at
the top
yeah the sendings are somewhat intuitive
here with the one decisive game in the
round here wesley uh half a point ahead
of the field and a full point ahead of
shakira marijaro who he did today
that's the extent of the study that's
how it works uh very nice uh four draws
uh we also alejandro uh we have certain
predictions uh
that we just want to review uh remind
know i mean ourselves know we we didn't
see them you know
i think we have one the center
no we have one shared oh that's that's
not fair yeah we have one share look at
that everybody pick different players
except for christian and peter exactly
conclusion there
absolutely yeah
that that goes to show a
wide variety
of yeah we definitely have
views yeah we definitely have not
exhausted the
the the amount of favorites in this
tournament is so high
and let's jump to bucharest for your for
the final thoughts uh from romania
well i i have to say guys that this was
a great start to the event a lot of
exciting games sure we got four draws
and only one decisive victory for wesley
but still all of the games were filled
with excitement fabiano caruana
continued the trend of playing a great
chess with the white pieces nevertheless
now we understand why ali reza is such a
hot prospect in the world of chess he
plays confident he plays fast and he
definitely showed us that he's going to
be a danger during the candidates and of
course
wesley just proves how good he is in the
grand chess tour we have an amazing
tournament
ahead of ourselves anastasia how about
yourself yeah it was an interesting
round and i think it's a bit of
improvement compared to the previous
stage which was happening here in
bucharest when all the games finished in
the draw so today we had a decisive
result which is good i believe for any
day and i was also impressed with wesley
saw technique today in his game against
shahriar but also knowing shakuriya that
he doesn't really like to defend such
kind of positions without control play
yeah i knew it's going to be really hard
for him let's say and of course
impressed with wesley whom i just
saw in berlin when he won this grand
prix event so impressive today
definitely a lot of exciting chess ahead
of us and well we have the best chess
players on the planet guys how about
yourselves nah i think you said it uh
very well yourselves and uh
alejandro day one in our belts uh final
thoughts
uh yeah well we had one decisive result
honestly too many fizzles it does make
me miss the format of the american cup
i'll go ahead and say it but it's a ron
roven it's a different type of
tournament it's a long one ahead and
it's part of a tour so the players are
definitely pulling for position and
wesley he just jumps straight out of the
gate takes advantage of a weekend
mamadiaro fan well it's all been about
wesley today as we had a bunch of draws
let's see if we can keep up the pace
thank you very much and
peter i want to say once again
big saint louis welcome to you thank you
very much
very good to be here and uh
i just want to say to everybody thank
you so much for sharing your
sharing your day with us uh join us
tomorrow same time same channel we'll be
here absolutely absolutely see you
tomorrow
[Music]
so
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the
saint louis chess club any reproduction
or distribution of this content without
the express written consent of the st
louis chess club is prohibited
you